okay good evening ladies and gentlemen
and welcome to this evening's planning
committee a - Peter Richards I'm going
to be chairing tonight's meeting before
we start forming starts if I could ask
you all to turn your phone's to silent
and keep them on silence throughout I
recognize that there is a need sometimes
for phones to be used so I'm okay with
that but provided unsung and they don't
disrupt the flow of our meeting the
meeting is being filmed for broadcast
after day to date so if you wanted to
catch up with what's happened you can
watch on YouTube tomorrow it seems
unlikely but it's there if you need it
it is a it is not a public meeting we
have a meeting with public participation
so only those who register to speak will
be allowed to speak and at that time you
will be invited up to sit in front of us
and speak at that stage but I would ask
that those of you in the gallery to
refrain from shouting out so that we can
conduct our I'm meeting appropriately if
I introduce our officer to my far right
we have banks from committee services
and loss chambers to my immediate right
and starting all the way over to our
left we are varying in weather Stern ami
flute I was causing that extra clarity
and Richard Gardner Richard is our
planning manager and has a very brief
statement he wants to make Thank You mr.
chairman good evening everyone my role
tonight is to provide imparted advice
and to clarify any planning issues that
arise and to assist members decision
taking I'm bound by the code of the
Royal Town Planning Institute their code
of Professional Conduct and planning
committee members not bound by advice
from officers or by their
recommendations thank you very much
apologies for absence do we have any
Thank You chairman we've got apologies
from councillors Eden and Kendall
of us thank you very much and any
disclosures of interest none from our
members any from our office oh sorry
council member for one mr. chairman will
you be speaking thank you one for me
chair item 9 Ellington I live in the
village and I'd volunteer on the
neighbourhood plan steering group so I
know the parish council speaker Mr
Osborne I don't know the applicant I
don't think this affects my ability to
give impartial advice the item thank you
very much
minutes members are you happy that the
minutes within your own gender pack are
true and accurate and I can sign them
after the meeting tonight yep thank you
very much okay so to our first
application then which is application
1900 275 very that 78 settings in road
traffic on Aven our presenting officer
is Stuart Fletcher over to you Thank You
chairman good evening this proposal is
seeking a variation of condition two of
planning permission reference 17 forward
slash zero one four seven four four
slash ful this approval was issued on
the 9th of November and 2017 and granted
permission for the demolition of the
existing and erection of a replacement
dwelling and detached outbuilding the
condition of subjectivist variation as
evening applies to be approved plans the
application site is within the builds
barrier boundary of stratford-upon-avon
to the south of tintin Road as indicated
by this black dots on the plan here we
see the application sites outlined in
red one can also see that the
application site is in a conservation
area as illustrated by the Purple Line
here we have an a satellite image of the
application site supervised by red arrow
here we now have the the front of the
existing dwelling as is here we have the
rear the existing - a link once suddenly
garden here we're now stood on the
Western wizard next to the western
elevation of the existing dwelling
to the boundary with number 76 Tim
Burton wrote here we are now stood again
in the garden looking northeast woods
towards the maple property on the other
side number 80 a here we have the
proposed site layout plan one could see
a summary of those changes Illustrated
these comprise a new d-link Road an
altered front drive Arrangements an
increased fort projection of the
approved garage the approved layout
whether or not you can see it or not is
highlighted by a dotted pink line on
this plan here showing what has been
approved with the black line showing
what's currently being proposed there's
also then an increase in footprint on
this westernmost elevation here showing
again the approved layouts in the dasu
pink line and the most variation of
subjects for this applications evening
here we have now the proposed front
elevation detailing the changes I've
tried to highlight as much as I can
what's basically is being varies in
terms of the visible front elevation
highlighted by the red circle you can
see here this elements here the
single-story element closest to number
76 is part of the variation of condition
this evening the rest of the elevation
and the other element here is this for
purchasing Garrett has been brought
forward with said Colonel Ann Timson
wrote this for petition Garrett has been
brought forward approximately 800
millimeters further forward the
elevation otherwise is the front
elevation otherwise as you see it there
was the elevation that was approved in
November 2017 you can see the africans
have avoided a red line there's actually
signify what the extent of the current
dwelling as it currently sits here we
see the proposed side elevation again
detailing those proposed changes and
here we see the proposed basement which
is supposed to be enlarged in addition
as part of this variation condition
clearly subterranean obviously a bigger
basement the principle of a replacement
dwelling is already accepted on this
site and is within the borough boundary
given the relatively minor alterations
proposed site specific issues regarding
good design impacts of heritage assets
and maintaining neighboring amenity have
all been deemed to be acceptable in the
gender pack is therefore recommended
that planning permission is granted as
set out in the reports chairman the
recognition is to grant the reasons to
some pages eighteen of your agenda packs
thank you Thank You Stuart okay if we go
in that case straight to our speakers we
have no one from the parent town council
so I have our first because as mr.
Howard Thomas and mr. Peter Phipps along
with mr. Nicholas Butler from CP re are
you all coming up together but you've
got nothing to do you're not gonna be
speaking given you're registered if
you'd like to come up and sit and then
it makes things a little easier if we do
have questions for you directly
thank you so we know who mr. Butler is
gentlemen I'm not sure which of you is
mr. Howard Thomas that's your good self
okay and that makes you mr. Phipps
in that case good evening welcome you
have three minutes for three minutes
between the two of you how would you
like to split your time okay thank you
and I understand there might have been
some slides that were dropped off all
those seem to have gone correct with are
there any within the slides you've seen
that you want so this one and then the
one with the cut that one okay and at
what point do you want these shown or
can we can we assume that members have
seen and noted them and you can refer to
them let's do that well because
otherwise we I don't want this meeting
to to go on too long but I do I want to
make sure you are heard okay which one
would you like
okay
okay we'll keep that one on screen for
you how about that no time okay so if
there's a button in the middle if you
want to press that right you're on
you've got three minutes I'll give you a
30-second warning look if that's all
right I mean a second warning from to
the end oh I see so you're gonna give me
a warning when I start you can start
whenever you're ready
and I like until I have done this before
but unfortunately it's been it's been a
long time this process has been going so
I just want to know when I'm supposed to
start that's all whenever you're ready
okay well I appreciate can I be foot
before I start just say I appreciate the
council is being here and I'm listening
so thank you very much
let me just say I'll start now then okay
the applicant wants to increase the
volume and footprint of the dwelling
again having previously reduced it to
gain approval the house is 11,000 square
feet above the ground and a hundred
percent larger than the existing house
the view of the situation doesn't show
everything but we had an aerial view
which cannot be shown because of time
but one thing we'd want you to notice
the mature landscaping on the boundaries
which I think some of you are seen on
the site visit the inspector considered
this a significant asset within the
conservation area it also provides
privacy objections from seventy six
relate to closeness and privacy issues
that can be seen at the bottom of that
diagram the revised footprint prints 78
closer to 76 its boundaries by 1.4
meters this increases the risk of damage
or even extinction of the image
your head the sideways roots will be
affected despite conditioned protective
measures a swimming pool at 76 which you
can see on the other side of that thing
is runs close to the boundary and is at
risk for structural damage caused by the
vibration of heavy plant equipment the
removal of huge amount of Earth could
cause soil movement the driveway now
extends closer to 76 this courtyard and
living area that can be seen as well
were on that diagram currently it's
private because of thick planting the
concern is that this will be damaged or
destroyed the objections from ata about
the new link road the variation
introduces a new d-link driveway from
the garage to the house this projects to
the boundary with ata
the plans which you have already seen
allow a 11 cars in the basement for in
the garage - in the house and plentiful
parking in the drive we are led to
believe a company called Oscar Jacobs
are currently trading cars from the
premises given the potential to store so
many cars on the property will this
continue the 1,000 square feet 12 feet
high building in the garden once
referred to as a workshop he's now
referred to as a garage on page a2 the
office as a report what does this imply
30 seconds the building has been
approved on condition that it is to be
used only for purposes ancillary to the
enjoyment to the building the applicant
had said it was for garden and
recreational equipment
note that the Town Council said no rep
subject to there being no vehicle access
between the proposed dwelling and ata an
application from 52 Teddington Road
which involved a similar side driveway
was refused upon appeal the pectus said
that such driveways were not a strong
characteristic of the conservation area
even if they were not on public
mr. comments I'm afraid I'm gonna have
to RT to wrap up you've just gone over
your three minutes now can I just can I
just can I just summarize which is what
I was going to do we urge you to refuse
this application on the grounds of
potential damage to mature planting
affecting privacy damage to foundations
lack of clarity about the possible use
of the garden building now renamed
garage apparently and the
uncharacteristic side driveway thank you
for being so kind as to allow me to now
summarize thank you very much thank you
very much members do we have any
questions for the three gentlemen in
front of you okay in that case thank you
very much for your inputs please make
your way back into the public gallery
thank you so our next speaker is mr.
Oliver Spicer who is the applicants for
the Atkins agent
agent I think good evening welcome you
know the drill
you have three minutes and we have
constructed over two minutes in this
presentation that's okay yeah I mean
we've got that well that one up so I'm
quite happy for this one to remain if
that's all right with me it was a
photograph on there just looking down
the side of the house looking towards
the shed on the side with possible great
thank you
okay three minutes when you're ready
thank you good evenin one time
soliciting its applications of variation
to a full application to replacement
dwelling a few years old now than we've
a long process to get to a half the
application asks for two small things
one is a to increase the width by just
over meet on this side the surf you
should consume the photograph is a kind
of soft black play area by the form of
swimming pool it's filled in the
concrete which is still there the
boundary on the left that you can see
which is raised with trees and hedging
it's completely unchanged and won't be
touched the proposed building is near
the white mended building on the right
but the the ground is made of ground and
will need to be remediated as part of
the technical design of this project one
of the reasons it took so long to get
where we have I can assure you that will
be done properly and there'll be no
disruption to any of the neighbors and
the second area of the application is a
slight increase on the basement this is
in a reason for this is to accommodate
animal plant area for the building and
the quality that is of a sufficient
attenuation therefore other equipment
within the basement is not a noisy and
that's why it's been made slightly
larger to accommodate that we've in
address within the slide show the
physical changes which off the nature
which are the below ground or a very
minor nature that been happy appear
behind the hedgerow are not really
visually seeable can live on the main
tintin road the area which I think has
been described as a deepening growth we
have been working with residents for the
number of years on this project and the
count that
all member more was in 100m agreement
however we try not best
the reason the d-link road as it's been
known on his annotating party
application we said that our client who
has a car collector wants to have a car
within his house the only way happening
is if it can be transported on a firm
surface it's been specified as grass
Creek which is used in many places in
this district
it's grant with a web structure very
commonly used it became the state's
permeable it's not a road or as it's
been described lessor it's a surface
which can take a car or vehicle to be
crossed over into the side of the house
as there are clients an applicant would
like in the future so that's that's mine
it's one civilian evening if you've any
questions I'm happy to answer
Thomas thank you very much well within
your time members questions Casso
jennings first this is a quick question
is it being run with all the car at the
Manta cars eyes if you run commercially
the properties of residential dwelling
and it's not I think the company that
was suggested in the earlier discussion
was his based at Ulster Kim Morton Kim
Morton he'll say that cars are there are
clients cars they're collector cars
cancer Perry good evening mr. Spicer the
one of the objectives raised their
concern about the landscaping in the
hedgerows I just wonder whether you can
just reconfirm but because I gather from
your own presentation
you said they were going to be retained
all the border landscape could you just
go give us a bit more detail about that
because obviously the objectors and
neighbors are concerned about the border
hedgerows and landscaping sure so this
application isn't proposed to change
alter any of the landscape in which
we've already been approved that's
already been approved is applications a
minor change to the size of the building
and then one side and the opposite side
the baton level
no changes to us already been approved
Casa pants I did go on the site visit
the you heads there is that owned by the
applicant forming the picture on this
yes I believe so
it's visible there was a ecological and
landscape assessment and a mitigation
strategy been in places for landscape
design which is part of the original
application which has been approved
which maintains all of that hedge
there was route protection barrier
massive installed within that to make
sure that no damage to that hedgerow the
new construction on this side of the
building which is in the photograph is
in excess of six meters from the
boundary so in any normal you know
development and white and put to version
house down there this comes if it's not
closed boundary so looking at the
picture the new development doesn't come
to where the shrubs oh okay okay members
any further questions
no thank you very much so our next
speaker its council Roth that's Roth I'd
like to make you a forward
Castlerock can we focus on the meeting
please so you know drill you have five
minutes when you're ready we will start
climbing okay we talked at the committee
last time about the hedge run in between
76 and 78 to Lincoln Road and we
discussed how important this hedge was
to the privacy of the occupants of 70 60
Lincoln Road it is over ten foot high
and when established would discuss at
the last committee about damage to the
hedge with construction vehicles and it
was thought at the time that appropriate
mitigation would take place
however this variation is asking that
the building 78132 mode is to move 1.4
meters closer to the hedge the hedge
will be seriously compromised by this
the roots of the hedge go horizontally
and therefore the building works will
damage the roots it is all very well the
applicant stating that the hedge will be
replaced if damage occurs but there is
no way that this scale and size of hedge
can be replicated or replaced powered
construction vehicles access the side of
the building the gap will be so small
and without doubt the hedge routes will
be damaged this building should go back
to the original position in order to
preserve this vital screening and
established hedge I was a little
disappointed that the cyclists only
looked at the hedge from the applicants
viewpoint in my view you should have
looked at both sides that you will have
seen only half of the picture when it
comes to the hedge you were off
affordably opportunity to do this but
the promise said there wasn't enough
time this email to the residents of 76
also by digging down further underground
in order to make the underground parking
bigger this could have a detrimental
effect of the structure of the pool at
76 digging to Road this digging will be
right next door to the pool and any
vibration against the pool foundation
will have an impact on the water there
could also be potential for structural
damage caused when excavating the
unusually deep foundations with risk to
88 innings
foundations as well as the swimming pool
removing huge amounts of Earth could
cause soil movement to have an impact on
the neighboring properties there needs
to be constant monitoring of any
potential damage or movement this needs
to be a condition regarding the other
side of the building adjacent to 88
Edenton Road where there is a tarmac
horseshoe road from the garage to the
inside of the house if you look at the
inspectors report point 14 on refusing
the building in the garden of 52
tootington Road albeit three years ago
you will see that he states the proposal
would introduce a substantial new built
form and hard surface areas for access
and parking into undeveloped garden
space which currently is a positive
contribution to the spaces field around
the property he goes on to say that he
considers that the new built form would
appear as a visually disruptive and
unwelcome intrusion into a generally
open and long space I accept that the
dwelling itself would be largely
shielded from the public view
irrespective the requirement for
development proposals to prefer preserve
or enhance the character or appearance
of stratford-upon-avon applies with
equal force whether or not the proposal
is prominent or in public view the
occupants will see this horseshoe road
in full view from their windows and will
see cars going from the garage along
down the side and into the house and
back again the driving of all the
classic cars that this new development
should be confined to the front drive
and not down the side of the house along
the side of number 80 a we have concerns
regarding what the planners described as
a garage page a to the report the
approval was for a garden store workshop
to store mowers and bytes that approval
must be adhered to and not used as a
workshop for the applicants
high-performance cars the neighbors must
not be subjected to these car engine
noises running alongside the garden
these variations should be refused and
this house should not be made bigger
than it already is it is already
substantially bigger which contributes
policy cs20 and if you look in your the
statement in the updates
it's two hundred and thirty five point
seven percent increase therefore it
should be refused
[Applause]
thank you very much counselor members
any questions cancer Perry
good evening counselor Ralph I've got
two two questions if I may
obviously Stratford town council have
come forward with no reps was that a
unanimous decision obviously you you are
being the mayor of Stratford town
council I'd be interested to hear your
views on that in their review of this
application and also if you could just
be a bit more specific on your material
planning reasons for the refusal okay I
am their staff to promote and I am a
town councillor I don't determine the
planning so I have no idea whether it
was unanimous or not secondly in answer
your second question there are material
planning reasons the damage to the hedge
the house moving closer and the deeper
excavation of the soil could damage the
fabrication the foundations of houses
either side plus also a tarmacked
Road at the side of the house and that's
why I highlighted the inspectors report
on 52 didn't emerge and it is in a
conservation area Thank You council
Jennings did you signal no any other
member want to ask cancer off the
question in that case that's Rob thank
you very much sir members we are now
over two points of clarification with
our offices anyone would like cancer
parry yeah I just would like some
clarifications on the possible addition
if we reminded to grant on the
conditions particularly on the building
wreck side in terms of the to combat any
concern on removal of quantities of soil
and the impact it might have on the
neighboring property in terms of being
able to monitor and also in the report
it mentioned there was concern raised
and that a condition could be put that
vehicles couldn't go down one of the
side side areas and I just would like
some clarification on those if we were
minded to grant if if on those
additional conditions thank you I can
partly address your one of your comments
relating to potential movement of
vehicles as specific construction
management construction vehicles
potentially a construction management
plan on the previous approval has now
been formally assessed to reuse and
discharged that would be included on any
were members minor to approve again this
evening that would be a condition pace
whereby that would be controlled and
strict measures be ensured that the
consideration side of it would be
mitigated against as best as we can
essentially on that specific point
on your first point counts are Perry
regarding the the basement your question
was about what happens to the spoil as
it gets okay that would be taken
off-site and disposed of or reused
somewhere else but that's not part of
this application if it were then that
would be an engineering operation that
would be part you know that there would
be plans and levels relating to that
it's just to respond to the concerns
made by the objectors on the impact of
the neighboring property but presumably
the engineering surveys and that side of
things
you're totally satisfied with all of
that it would need would need to meet
the building regulations of course but
that's separate from planning what
councillor Barnes first this application
is to increase the size of the house
towards the u H are the conditions that
are obviously on the whole of that edge
to safeguard
recommended conditions six concerns tree
and hedge protection so that would look
to protect the hedge particularly in the
areas where the development would come
closest to it but to my mind it wouldn't
be necessary to do that further down the
garden I did go on the side visit but I
was just thinking it's not secure we
needed to be security yeah we would
expect that scheme to be secure where
there's the greatest risk of incursion
into that hedge area but as I said
further down the garden that risk is
much less but around the building area
we'd expect the usual form of hedge
Protection fencing cancer Allen could I
just see the extent of the basement on
the slides so look at this can use it
are you able to identify the part that's
being extended towards number 676 the
closest point that
yeah yes I'm just trying to determine
the extent of it over the over the site
Catherine do you have other questions as
well mother was trying to work it out
that's fine is the type of construction
of the basement and considered a
material planning consideration based on
the disruption that this might cause for
neighboring residents during
construction process the construction
process would be considered in two ways
as per your report on page eighteen
condition 8 requires a construction
management plan and that would specify
things like hours of operation those
kind of things but also noise and
disturbance that's covered by the
environmental protection regulations so
there's a level of protection afforded
through different regulations from
planning structural engineering the type
of construction of the basement
retaining walls will depend on the
disruption of the ground and the soil
around the property and what impact that
might have so it can be critical
especially when looking at the
disturbance of root systems and apron
properties and I wasn't sure if that was
considered in the original application
or here at all with regard to the impact
on the root systems of the hedges on
either side we're satisfied that there's
enough distance that it could still come
forward without having a negligible
impact on sorry a harmful impact on
those hedgerows did you manage to get a
response about the size so the where
it's extended
you'll have to I've got a plan here
which has been provided by the
applicants which is partly to do with
some of the archaeological proposed
works
I might basically there are a few
different light colored lines aged
denoting what has already been approved
with regard to the basement and then
there's a blue line detailing the
proposed basement extent currently the
does that slide help you can silent are
you satisfied you've had a response to
your question marvelous thank you castes
thank chairman cattle are off made
reference to tarmac and was referring to
previous inspectors report elsewhere and
the agent referred to grass Crete are
they both talking about the same area as
far as the landscaping is concerned the
yes the the the road elements that's on
your proposed layout plan that is but as
the agent referred to that is proposed
to be a grass Crete quality not a tarmac
because you see denoted on the front
drive and the two different materials
for that reason thank you I'm throwing
on from that if four are going to take
one we were able to get a car down the
back of that area without that grass
cream if they were trees that one would
be able to do that on their own property
anyway wouldn't they regardless of
whether there is or isn't erosion that
is correct so we thought you could drive
into the back garden any oh okay that's
good tonight
okay cancel our off do you have a point
to raise as a matter of facts of
clarification or would you like to come
forward
I just want to make the point of
clarification that the last approved
application the there was a condition
about the hedge because the committee
were very concerned about the hedge you
are now moving the building 1.4 meters
closer to that hedge and there is the
same condition there must be a different
condition or it shouldn't be approved
because that hedge will die it's ten
foot high okay thank you my
understanding and I'm a scoffs just to
clarify is that the condition that was
on the original you're welcome to make
your way back the condition and the
original application is being carried
over so that still applies is that
correct good thank you okay members in
that case we'll open up to debate who
would like to kick us off councillor
Perry looks excited first of all I think
I can I do understand from the objective
perspective their concerns about this
application but I think that more
relates to the it started off with the
full application which has already been
approved and therefore what we're
looking at today is the variation and
it's the additional aspects to to it and
so one is not looking at the whole
application because we have approval
already in principle that was approved
back in November 2017 I do have concerns
about the obviously that the hedgerow
that councillor Rolf has mentioned
however I am NOT an expert in
landscaping or root development for
hedges and therefore clearly our
planning team will have consulted with
our trillion hedge specialists within
the planning
and on the basis of what we have in
front of us I cannot see any substantial
harm in the variation that's put forward
to us this evening and therefore I can't
see any material planning reason on the
basis of the variation that's in front
of us and will therefore be going with
the offices recommendation to grant
thank you is that proposal to grant I'm
happy to grant marvelous thank you
anyone else like to speak councillor
Barnes mr. chairman this is a variation
to send the house 1.4 meters a keys
where there was a swimming pool it does
appear that the extension doesn't go as
far as the swimming pool so in that
respect the wall that's still in the
ground or whatever excavation has to be
done I don't think will affect the hedge
if we want more conditions I'm quite
active for those to be put on but I
don't see any planning reason for
refusal okay thank you ever played
seconder does anyone else want to have
an interesting in that case we'll go for
a vote so we have a proposal and
seconded to grant application 1900 to 75
and very in line with the officers
report the conditions sent out within
that and the update sheet could I please
have a show of hands
five chairmen and those against one
Channel marvelous thank you in that case
committee grant application 1900 275
very thank you very much
[Applause]
so if we then move to our second item
which is item 1901 five four five r.e.m
this is for the British gateway reserved
matters will have Alice kosnett
as our presenting officer Alice when you
are satin comfortable please begin when
you're ready Thank You chairman
the application site which is denoted by
the black dot in the center of the plan
is located on the edge of the built-up
area accredit the site as outlined in
red forms part of the wider
redditch gateway site read each gateway
in its entirety was granted outline
planning permission for 32 hectares of
employment land for business and
industrial uses with full permission
granted for the signalized access
junction on the commentary highway the
application before members this evening
seeks approval for the reserved matters
relating to appearance landscaping
layout scale and internal access for the
north and development parcel being the
parts of Redditch gateway to the north
of the Coventry highway this slide shows
the site location plan for this reserved
matters application on the left-hand
side in the context of the wider
redditch gateway site the existing
Business Park to the west of the site is
shaded purple woodland to its north
shaded green and gray to stylistic Gorka
tall is the building that can be seen to
the north east of the site here the plan
on the right-hand side of the slide
shows the entirety of the redditch
gateway site in the context of the local
authority boundaries as the reserve
matter site falls in Stratford in
Bromsgrove identical applications have
been submitted to both authorities here
the proposed layout can be seen a
building proposed be used Class B 8
storage and distribution with ancillary
office floor space is proposed with
associated infrastructure car parking
and landscaping surface shards and HDV
parking would be to the north west and
south of the building with associated
cars cycle and electric vehicle charging
spaces and bus shelters to the east
beyond which lies a significant area of
soft landscaping the diverted footpath
and Brook would be located in this area
of soft landscaping this plan shows the
landscape master plan and the high
quality landscape scheme proposed this
includes woodland planting orchard
planting new native hedgerows meadow
planting black poplar trees along a
current alignment of the black soars
Brook to assist in the interpretation of
the his
at county boundary and relocated veteran
trees the main b8 building would have a
maximum height of 16 point 2 meters it
would be clad in a mix of light and
darker gray cladding with a blue feature
strip along its top all doors windows
and shutters would have a dark gray
finish this photo is taken from the
southern side of commentary highway
looking toward the site the roofs of the
existing industrial buildings on Ravens
Bank Business Park can be seen in the
distance and this note was taken again
from commentary highway looking in an
easterly direction the site can be seen
on the left-hand side of the photo and
these photos show the existing
industrial unit of the adjacent Ravens
Bank Business Park having considered the
appearance landscaping layout scale and
internal access routes this reserved
matters application is considered to be
acceptable chairman the recommendation
is therefore to approve thank you chair
thank you very much let's move straight
to our first speaker who is mr. courtly
I think I'm hoping I'm pronouncing that
right
marvelous so I think you've also got to
read out for mrs. Barry the chair of
Governors it's matter of Green School is
that correct
so do you propose to read that first
okay you have three minutes for the
whole Lots just so you're aware okay
so when you're ready we'll start the
timer and I'll give you a 30-second
warning
you will have had update sheets or
reports and I must express my concerns
that she's Maureen speaking Maureen bury
my concern that your cancer is breached
greet procedures on the 31st of January
of 2018 this committee established
steeling group with terms of reference
which you should have received to help
review emerging development proposals
with regard to scale and appearance and
full engagement with local state coffers
and console t's working towards reserve
matters that the steering group has not
considered the application before
tonight your January 2018 committee and
the last two planning applications
considered by Bromsgrove and Stratford
the decision documents included the
wording the process will be controlled
by the steering group clearly this has
not happened this committee must honor
its decision and refer this application
to the steering group in his first in
the first instance that's mrs. Barry
needless to say I strongly concur with
mrs. Barry statement this committee must
honor each minute of the 31st of January
2018 and enable the steering group to
consider this application first in
respect of amongst other things light
pollution scale views landscaping color
schemes and layout that minute does not
state that the North site does not come
within the purview of the steering group
you need to read it
finally the developer is often called
this development the game changer yes it
is but it is not the best thing since
sliced bread it will cause damage and
have negative effects including
countering your cancers climate policy
for those reasons also the steering
group must consider this
education before this committee makes
its decision Thank You June mama thank
you very much well within your time
members for most questions I think it's
important that you understand the terms
of reference that have just been
referred to so I'm going to ask our
planning manager Richard just to read
out what they are and exactly what they
mean
Thank You mr. chairman
okay the terms of reference are as
follows the role of the steering group
is to facilitate full engagement with
local stakeholders and counsel teas as
part of the pre-application work in
drawing up the reserve matter schemes
the steering group will have particular
regard to the relationship between the
development site and its residential
neighbors particularly where it adjoins
the southwest and southern boundaries of
the de southern development parcel the
steering group will help review emerging
development proposals with particular
regard to scale and appearance in
relation to nearby properties and in
achieving high-quality design the
steering group will review details to be
submitted with regard to condition 19
HDTV routing strategy and condition 20
annual HDTV surveys prior to
consideration by the relevant planning
committee the sting group will meet to
consider proposals as and when they are
advised by the applicants in order to
make an effective contribution to the
working of the reserved matters
proposals and routing strategy stroke
surveys the steering group will not have
a right of veto for emerging application
proposals that will be an advisory body
the view of the steering group will be
reported to the planning committees on
this thank you very much
castle Vance you indicated you had the
question I think my question is sort of
without you would want to be kept
brought back
before we got to this point exactly
okay there's any other questions no okay
thank you very much yeah but Tamar next
speaker is mr. Joe I'm assuming it's mr.
Joe Russell
mrs. sheriff so I do apologize awful
assumption on my part
you are the applicant or excellence
agent I believe marvelous you have three
minutes so whenever you're ready to
start please do and I'll give you 30
second warning thank you the site
benefits from outline planning
permission is allocated and the
principle of developing this site for b1
b2 and b8 uses is firmly established
with strong County Council and LEP
support we're excited to before you
today with our first reserved matters
application members are being asked to
determine scale layout appearance
internal access and landscaping a
routing strategy has already been
approved for the site as has access to
the highway scale in layout conforms
with the approved parameters the
appearance of the building has been
considered in some detail
it was considered by members of Reddit
Borough Council twice and the colors
approved in principle within our outline
design and access statement in March of
this year we met with members of
Marlboro green and Studley Parish
Council many of these are members of the
steering group to which you've had
reference we shared with them our draft
proposals for the reserve matters
comments were expressed and we submitted
a color scheme we chose lighter shades
of gray cladding as a result of those
clients and thus has been reflected in
the application before you in July we
also met with the steering group and
agreed our HTV strategy at the end of
that meeting it was agreed that the next
time that group would meet would be for
the proposals for the South site and not
for
this site that was minted in terms of
our building efficiency we propose you
utilize heat recovery air source heat
pumps I can explain how these relate to
carbon emissions we've also designed the
roof to be ready to receive PV panels
and 10% of our parking spaces will be
fitted with Eva charging points
landscaping forms an integral part of
our application we now retain to further
mature Oaks and one further mature ash
than previously indicated we're
retaining further six more groups of
trees than previously before and in
addition we are going to be planting an
additional two hectares of new woodland
290 deciduous trees 82 conifers an
orchard over a thousand meters of
hedgerow four hectares of new grassland
meadow areas and eight ponds we'd like
to think that demonstrates our
commitment to the green infrastructure
which is the majority of the application
site within stratford district 30
seconds to reach this state today we've
worked with offices and console T's over
the course of the last few months to
result in there being no technical
objections to our proposal thank you
thank you very much members do we have
any questions
cancer bond Council advances I said we
met the steering group in July of this
year it was agreed at that meeting that
the next time they would like to meet
was to consider the sound foresight and
we also met with the Parish Council in
March thank you any other questions
No okay in that case thank you very much
for contribution now our next speaker
would speak cancer Henshaw Seraphin but
unfortunately he has sent his apologies
he has also sent a note to both myself
and Danny as the normal Jeff this
meeting which I shall read out to you
now verbatim so that's basic of the
consideration of reserved matters should
have been looked at by a meeting of the
steering group no such meeting has taken
place an exchange of emails are not the
same as a meeting where debate and
learning can take place it is difficult
to understand where the authority for
deviating from the terms of reference
comes from with regard to the question
of what scrutiny was required in
relation to the impact on residential
property is concerned it is clear that
there were that there was to be
particular regard for the southern
parcel however that that does not imply
that the rest or northern section
examined by the steering group may be to
point out the distance from the northern
section to properties that do not need
in this requirement the rules cannot be
made up as we go along the impact of
extra traffic with the amended
development has still not been examined
by the steering group because it simply
has not been allowed to meet many of us
did not accept that sorry many of us did
not accept that no further modeling was
necessary to base the refusal to remodel
on the route upon of the reiteration of
a marginal increase in square footage is
not acceptable
yours truly accounts their interest
elfin so please bear that in mind during
our deliberations and we now go to our
question of sources so anyone have any
questions for clarification counsel Adam
first just to clarify then like Michael
mixed message there but the applicants
just said that the steering group has
looked at this whereas
the objectives suggested it hasn't am I
just missing something
just to clarify through you chair the
steering groups met four times and that
was specifically to discuss the HTV
routing strategy conditioned on the
outline at the last meeting which was in
July the reserved matters had just been
submitted but hadn't been consulted on
but the applicant did advise that it had
been submitted and be consulted on the
following couple of weeks and at that
point I stipulated to members that the
wooden we will be bringing the northern
reserve matters to the steering group
for consideration because our reading of
the terms of references that it relates
to the southern parcel so they that was
minuted and they were circulated in
draft form to members of the steering
group and I didn't receive any responses
from any members of the steering group
to raise issue with the north and parcel
not being discussed at the steering
group Council Dixon Thank You chairman
question to the officers we've noticed
from the report that the building will
be Bream good standard and that
obviously refers to the building they're
all going to be a number of traffic
movements as a result of building if it
gets permission and goes ahead is it
reasonable for us to also actually seek
a condition that apart from a roof being
designed to take photovoltaics that a
element of that is definitely included
to say ten percent twenty percent for a
minimum requirement to help offset the
carbon of all those traffic journeys
thank you through you chair yes you're
quite right they've stated it will be
good to standard and there will be a lot
of traffic movements in terms of traffic
movements I would say that that's
already been accepted to outline stage
through the submission of the Transport
assessment in terms of requiring solar
photovoltaics the applicant has advised
that they are constructing the roof
ready for their installation officers
view is that we can't condition a
certain
which is put on or that they are
definitely put on the reason being that
our policy encourages rather than
specifically requires the provision of
renewable sources what what I will say
is I did quite what I will say so I did
question the applicant on this in
advance of the meeting and their
response was the current initial designs
of the scheme anticipate circa 530
square metres of panels will be required
to achieve the target EPC rating of a
however they've put the final designs of
the scheme will be with responsibility
of the contractor and they may well come
up with other means to achieve the
target EPC a rating however to my mind
they are stating that they will but it's
not necessarily going to definitely be
through solar voltaic panels anyone else
with any other questions
no in that case let's open some debate
if you would like to go first pass the
bonds I can't see really any reason that
we can't approve this application we had
other for these industrial sites where
schools have been concerned and the
County Council actually put in a pelican
crossing now so I understand the
school's concerned that I'm quite happy
to propose the opposite recommendation
Thank You Council Perry Thank You chair
I'd like to endorse what councillor
Barnes has actually said I would also
just like to add it's disappointing that
mapable Green Parish Council haven't
been here this evening having made the
objection which is one of the reasons
why this has come forward to committee
and on the basis of what counselor bond
authority has said I'm very happy to
second his proposal to grant thank you
very much anyone else want to have
anything else to say at this point no in
that case we have a proposal and a
seconder so if we could have a show of
hands for the
excuse me just a moment
forgive me the in the update sheet we do
have an amended condition so I'm going
to take it as read that your proposal
and seconds does include the conditions
as set out in the committee report and
in the update sheet to read it to cancel
bonds if the Parish Council oppose this
application and haven't come to speak
but why we going through this process
normally once when an objection has been
placed we will bring as you well know we
were bringing either through a parish
council or from a ward member from that
point anyone is able to register to
speak we did have two people or do have
two people register to speak so we're
continuing through it's the right thing
to do in my opinion particularly
something of this gap so those
additional conditions shifts we're clear
our details to be submitted relating to
mammal alleges to be included two
culverts and an amendment to condition
of proof plans notwithstanding lighting
details provided code by condition 39 of
the hybrid planning application and then
the variation number councillor Barnes
just so I'm clear are you your proposal
is as set out in the committee report
including that additional and amended
for condition that cancer very happy
with that in that case could we have a
show of hands for those in support of
that proposal committee resolved to
grant the application in line with the
committee report and of the additional
update sheet thank you ever so much
so we can move swiftly to next Tyson
which is item number so application
reference 1900 0 6 7 f UL southside
aston cantaloupe our presenting officer
is amy flute Amy over to you
Thank You chair the application sites
denoted by the black dot is a parcel of
land within the village of Aston can't
name a category for local service
village the site is washed over by the
green belt the application site is to
the west of number one Sunnyside the
site is nearby to a list of buildings to
the south which just outside the map
area public footpath a l9 free is
situated to the west of the application
site part of the AXA access with
Sunnyside falls in flood zone 2 but the
proposed siting of the dwelling and the
majority of the site is moving in flood
zone 1 planning permission is sought for
the erection of the dwelling which will
be set back from the highway with
off-road parking the site is had two
recent applications which have been
refused application 1703 five double
nine full proposed a dwelling which was
refused permission as it was considered
that the dwelling would impact the
street scene as a result of its citing
beyond the building line and lack of
visual gaps secondly application 18:02
free zero to full was refused due to the
impact of the proposed siting of the
dwelling on the street scene and the
lack of separation distances between
built form the proposed Freebird
dwelling would be two-story constructed
from red brick with a pitch tiled roof
with small canopy over the front door
and a single-story rear projection the
image this image is looking north
towards the application site the site's
relationship with adjoining properties
in particular in particular number one
Sunnyside to the to the east can be seen
this image is taken within the site
looking at properties to the west of the
application site at the
from within the site can now be seen
looking south towards the access of
Sunnyside the rear part of the plot can
now be seen with open countryside to the
north and now the site can be seen in
the wider streets in context the
principal of a dwelling is acceptable in
this location in accordance with CS 15
and we embark policies it would not have
a detrimental impact on heritage assets
of the character of the street scene
neighboring immunity or flood risk
chairman the recommendation is to grant
the application subject to the
conditions and notes as detailed within
the committee report thank you
very good thank you very much our first
speaker is cancer Lesley Harvey from
Aston can't Irish counsel if you would
like to make your way forward good
evening
thank you very much for coming and
giving them cheering but you have
presumably worked out by now that it's
three minutes now give you a 30-second
warning
whenever you're ready please begin okay
I want to say first of all that I am in
no way representative of the feeling
within the parish and there is extensive
I guess against what I would say okay
it's recommended if you have grant of
this property
several parish members are here and
there was some confusion about whether
they could speak on often as a result
many of them have not come to speak
because they understood they couldn't
I'd like to just make that point first
of all our major concern really is on
the subjectivity part of the
recommendation to grant at the first
stage the recommendation was to refuse
and that the second stage was again and
at that point the applicant was trying
to work with the officers to find a
potential solution an email that was
sent from the officer to that applicant
clearly stated that in her opinion no
change could be made that would make
that application grant able and now we
see before us a new application which in
our opinion the barre is almost
marginally if any at all subject I think
it's a 45 degree angle movement but it
hasn't made any material difference in
our view the overall property is still
incongruent
in our opinion with the rest of that
site it is directly opposite and
adjacent to listed buildings and one of
the references is made to the separation
of the road and then the hedgerow around
a listed building what a hetero is not a
permanent structure and it's not a
permanent item that could should be
considered in fact that that is not a
hedgerow it's um it's a conifer hedge
a set of conifer trees which are badly
infected and actually need replacing
and the residents as I understand it are
in the process of making an application
for that the second consideration was
the proximity to the house next door
that is still remained at 2 meters which
we believe is extremely close and is not
in any way similar to the rest of
Sunnyside so whilst we understand the
officers view that because properties to
the left looking at it to the west are
different to those that are in Sunnyside
we don't believe that that sufficient
reason to approve I'd also like to say
that that as a parish council we have
produced a parish plan and within that
we fully support infill sites and have
in fact got several recently recommended
and granted and built but in this case
we don't feel that the particular
property the dwelling that's been
proposed is appropriate on that site and
I think that's it thank you fantastic
thank you very much do you have any
questions councillor bonds yes if you
look at the photographs could we put
that one up please okay go back to that
one that will help
that's one so if you look at the left at
the right hand side of that photograph
you'll see a a conifer hedge that's the
listed that's one of the listed
buildings and there is another
photograph which I think was just before
this one there and that's the other one
no that's the second lot and next to
that there are another three so it's not
one or two just to clarify the white
building in the photograph isn't listed
I'm sorry it's the one next door to
right it's the one next door to it I beg
your pardon that is that's my friend
councillor Perry
hello good evening I wonder whether you
can just advise when was your parish
plan carried out and within that did you
have carry out a housing needs to the
verb tool we're right in the middle of
the housing needs survey so we did the
parish plan first and published it and
got it ratified and so on and it is
distributed and the reason we did it
that way is because historically within
our parish we owned we're only a
community of 220 dwellings and our
response rate has always been very low
and so we felt that it would be more
relevant to publish the plan first which
identified already a minimum of between
10 and 12 20 that we should accommodate
and we were very happy with that and at
that point we told everybody that a
housing survey would then be done and
since then we have distributed them so
far we've got a much higher response
rate than we've had before based on we
believe that we did it in two parts and
got the buy-in really from the neighbors
first okay anyone else with any further
questions
can't see your your menthe friend didn't
work the edge that was seen there yes
our conifers etc do you know it's
probably an unfair question in the
ownership of the plot that's being
developed or suggested no debate so it's
part of the property that the officer
was referring to as it is listed that
created a barrier okay thank you okay
okay if there are no further questions
Thank You counsel Holly's thank you she
ate your input we do have no further
unless counselor for minutes with us we
have no further speakers so points of
clarification members do you have any
points of clarification for officers no
it would be helpful I think if we could
have an understanding of the difference
between what we're looking at now and
the previously refused if that's okay so
back in 2017 I didn't do it with the
application and that they proposed
always for an hour shape dwelling which
was cited as such it was quite far back
from the highway I can show you the
elevations which were proposed they that
was the proposed elevation so it wasn't
considered appropriate for the street
scene and there was concerns about
terracing effect and the bill the breach
of the building line going back to the
application which I dealt with while the
end of last year the the dwelling was
sited very close to number one and we
had concerns with the impact of
terracing effect because of the lack of
separation distances and it's it's a
position concerns within the street
scene and that's what's proposed now so
so the the actual layout of the building
the is exactly the same only it's now
been moved away from that boundary and
put on the other boundary and that has
what was allowed it's been more
acceptable that that's correct so since
the application in 2017 the design
obviously has changed but the design for
this application is as what was for the
previous application just in an
alternative location okay thank you
elevations was the word I was looking
for by the way in case you're wondering
councillor Dixon can you just confirm
the change in the separation from number
one please between the one that was was
refused ended last year
and this one okay I don't have the exact
separation distance figure off the top
of my head for 1802 free 0t but it was
less than two meters which is what set
out in the development requires SPD as
the required minimum separation distance
between buildings and the proposed if I
go back to the site plan development
that that would accord with the required
separation distance yeah I think it's
two point five meters
okay counsel Jennings so on the design
side I'm presuming this all the same
brick so ready if you didn't you went
there after being built you wouldn't
know they very they're intending to
build the bricks from rebec that you'll
see for my recommendation that there is
a condition recommended for materials so
that we can control and make sure that
what they are intending to build the
property out in will be appropriate for
and the widest reason any other
questions for offices Council on when
regarding the street seem I appreciate a
log works gone it into the front
elevation for to tie in with those in
satisfied
does appear that there is access down
the water effectively the side of the
proposed building is that considered the
street scene even though it's the side
of this proposed site as obviously there
are houses opposite on the other side of
the road and it would it would be
considered part of the street scene but
obviously I think it's quite clear if I
show you that there's two sort of
character areas to the street scene so
you've got sunny side here which is
obviously quite uniform and then the
properties which are to the west of the
applications are a very similar in
design to what you can see here
Chancellor Bantz this application has
been refused twice before was it the
offices refusal
they were refused under delegated
authority yeah okay now you believe that
the reasons have been addressed okay if
we have no further questions for
clarification then oh you have notice to
debate who would like to start if no one
what start I'll pick on someone it's me
again isn't it
try to encourage my colleagues that's
why I was holding back number number one
apart from anything else it's it's good
to see that the officers working closely
with the applicant to try and overcome
obstacles really to find a suitable
design that's acceptable from a planning
perspective and it's always welcome to
see a small detached property come
forward whilst I understand the concerns
of the parish council looking at it on
the face of it it has been extremely
well scrutinized by the planning team
because it's taken this time to come
forward with a design that's acceptable
I can't see any planning reason not to
go with grant and therefore wish to
propose to grant approval for this
application
Marcus Thank You councillor Jones board
anyone else wants anything at this point
no good in that case we have a proposal
and a seconder to grant in line with his
officers recommendation and update
sheets could I have a show of hands who
will in that case committee resolves to
grant application 1900 0 6 7 fu L a me
thank you very much and we will then
move swiftly on to our next item which
is application 1900 3 6 1 ful over the
little house and our presenting officer
is Erin weather
so I forgive it states in general which
is Hannah you may have noticed we have a
little pop-up in our right hand corner
and we're trying to get rid of it it's a
little frustrating we're having
technical difficulties in doing say no
the less we shall carry on Aaron
whenever you're ready if you'd like to
start the application site lies to the
north of compact settlement had
identified by the black dot on this plan
this slide identifies the application
site hatched in red just here the site
is located at the end of school lane
which forms part of the adopted highway
and paused within the Felton Park
special landscape area a row of grade 2
listed buildings lights the south of the
site identified in red on this slide so
just here to the north of the site lies
a southernmost edge of Compton bernie
greatest are registered Park and Gardens
which is shown by the brown line which
is this line here from the plan to the
north of the site lies ancient woodland
known as the rides which is shown by the
green hatching on the plan so it's this
area here as rides which K is up to the
north of the application site public
right-of-way SD eight six lies to the
south west of the site and is shown by
the green solid line which is this line
here to the south east of the site lies
public right-of-way SD eight seven B
which is sewn by the green dashed line
in this location here the property the
little house lies across to the west of
the access to the property adhere and
the work proposed to taking place east
across the public highway
plant information is sort of the
enlightenment of an existing parking
area which serves a property the little
house and the erection of a retaining
wall this slide shows the proposed plans
we've got a little house on the
left-hand side
the public highway comes up through the
center this is the existing parking area
and the enlarged parking area to the
right hand side of the image you can see
the wall going around to the north the
east and the south and stairs to the
north which go up to the rides and
provide access the gates of enabling
property are located approximately here
drainage is proposed and you can see the
drainage system would be subterranean
and this would be the line of the
drainage just here this slider is
proposed elevations for development the
Waller to propose to be finished in
stone tomb actually existing so you've
got along here you can see the steps
going up the existing garage and the
wall along the North elevation and the
section to the side too is a section of
the water proposed this slider is a
photograph looking north towards site
from the public highway for the sites at
the top end you've got the little house
on the left-hand side
for grade 2 listed buildings to the left
of the image just here and you can see
their access points are slightly lower
than the public highway and the stepped
axis is down to each individual door and
their respective outbuildings to the
right of the image this slide shows the
gate to keepers cottage the little house
is on the left-hand side this is on the
public highway and the area of parking
is to the right this photograph is
planning around so you've got the gate
just behind the image here to the left
as you're going along with the stepped
access going up into the ride you can
cheat see the change in ground levels
and the proposed parking area is just
about here with the wall going around to
the north the east and as we pan around
looking around again the wall to the
south the garage for the property is
just here see the parking area to the
left-hand side
this photograph is taken looking south
the little houses on the right-hand side
it's carriages to the left parking areas
to the left hand
looking down the public highway the
little cottages are on the right-hand
side and the outbuildings are on the
left the proposal it's considered to be
in principle acceptable and it's not
considered to raise any adverse impact
on the character the area neighboring
dwellings and mannaseo flood risk
subject to conditions it's therefore
recommended that planning permission be
granted for the reason set out in the
report thank you thank you very much
our first speaker tonight is our parish
council vice chairman Dr Goode heads if
you'd like to make your way forward that
with grace you have three minutes you
can start whenever you're ready and I'll
give you a 30 second one there is a
button in the center of your microphone
that will turn it red just so you know
when it's on okay good evening this is
the the picture shown up there is the
third version of a retaining wall that
claims to represent what has been built
the structural engineer employed to
provoke to prove the adequacy of the
design wrote I was able to measure each
part of the wall and my measurements
concur with my description there are two
previous drawings showed a concrete base
450 millimeters deep to the bases at the
bottom there the base was below ground
level acting as a foundation following
two critical representations from the
parish council this third version of the
drawing appeared
it shows the concrete base now increased
in height the structural engineer gave
the reason that the previous versions
were not as built and that's a was that
a conversation was held with the Builder
eight months later she was told that the
base now concealed with stone was
actually 700 millimeters high and not
four hundred and fifty millimeters as
previously ident
this increase would conveniently allow
the bottom of the base to be below
ground level therefore increasing
stability could have the next slide
please
this photograph shows the concrete base
for the wall cast in shuttering clearly
sitting on top of the excavated ground
note also the reinforcing rods not
extending above the base could I have
the next slide please
this photograph shows the nature of the
soft clay which is collapsed while
unsupported again the bottom of the
shuttering is level with the excavated
ground cut up the next slide please
this shows the concrete base exposed
above ground level if the base was
indeed 700 millimeters deep there would
have to be a trench below the excavated
ground level to form a foundation the
photos prove that this does not exist
there is no foundation to this wall the
wall is built directly on top of the
excavated clay in July the Parish
Council obtained pro bono opinion from
an experienced charter civil engineer he
concluded that the calculations did not
relate to the wall as built but also
that no account had been taken of the
slope of the hillside and the steel
reinforcement bars were improperly
spliced the PC submitted a clear
executive summary of his analysis with
detailed calculations for verification
showing that the as-built structure is
unsafe in 30 seconds the committee
report has completely ignored our
representation and instead accepts
without question the opinion of the
structural engineer despite evidence
that the drawings are in connect
incorrect and the calculations are
flawed could I have to skip the next one
and have the final slide please
thank you this shows the so called
draining plat drainage plan this
drainage plan is nonsensical it shows
all water from the new development
either fed into a land rain increasing
the likelihood of groundwater flowing or
it shows water
going uphill in a channel drain which is
impossible just profess without your
time so if you could wrap that there's
no workable scheme here it completely
fails to demonstrate how harm is removed
from the list of cottages and therefore
fails to comply with zs4 Barba's thank
you marginally over but I think we can
accept that okay thank you members do
how many questions so I have one if I
may you mentioned your engineer that
considered the wall we haven't seen that
report we furnished with the full report
yes we have been yes I don't it was
formed the part of the the parish
councils the representation and it
hasn't been considered at all okay I
will raise that as a point of
clarification when we get to that point
okay strike somebody gets more detail
okay in that case that's it thank you
very much for you contradict you very
much our next speaker speaking on behalf
of our residents is mr. racin Miss
racing with fewer lights come forward
I'm pronouncing that correctly I hope
chairman just a point of information I'm
not clear if it's been made clear to you
this is retrospective thank you that
will be I was gonna raise that later on
but I think it's clear from the photos
it might be but you have three minutes
I'll give you a 30 second warning
towards the end just before can I just
introduce Who I am you've introduced me
but I need to explain to you I'm one of
the residents in the row of cottages yep
so whenever you're ready okay
I've only endorsed a parish councils
comments I'm also disappointed in the
lack of response to the key concerns
raised the incident has been a shock job
for me about the rides woodland the
officer mentioned it and hasn't
explained it I'm just really surprised
about the lack of information about this
application which has been presented to
you
I knew the rides woodland was an ancient
woodland from the 15th century however I
never really bothered about what that
really meant but our policymakers
clearly have bothered
including SDC which has strong policy in
line with national framework now the
committee report at page 66 is very
clear about policy you must refuse
development which is harmful to ancient
woodland unless there are wholly
exceptional reasons ie if there were an
overriding public benefit there was no
overriding public benefit in this
application so you should refuse it
sadly County ecology chosen to make no
representation and I presume this is a
sad impact on the savagely reduced
funding of our public services however a
month later The Woodlands trust did
respond then letter starts with a clear
objection no ifs no buts it will cause a
disturbance to the rides ancient
woodland now and in the
the work already done has been harmful
of the removal of semi natural habitat
lots of trees and removal of 300 tons of
soil and subsoil but also the noise dust
and the like pollution which are also
critical long term issues noise dust and
light from human activity but more
importantly the cumulative effects are
more harmful than the individual
incident ie it is continued its
continued proposed use would be a
greater harm in the long term we're
talking about the future not our time
now the stanlon advice of Natural
England is clear a buffer zone protects
ancient woodland it should be at least
15 metres and should consist of swimming
natural habitats the purpose of a buffer
zone is to protect ancient woodland and
individual trees in that woodland the
standard advice lists and describes
seven potential impacts of such nearby
development as its proposed and in my
view six of these will apply to this
case the policy is clear
you must refuse this application I'm
afraid the arguments in the fourth and
fifth paragraph of this section of the
report
thirty Seconds are confused and
inaccurate as they tried to build the
case to ignore the clear duty to issued
under paragraph 175 this week I have
provided your officers the latest
technical guidance from the Ministry of
Community and local government which
addressed both the issues of curtilage
and permitted development to which
paragraph 4 refers I still wait to
receive a response to my requests to
receive a reference to point me to the
definitive guidance and policy on which
those two paragraphs are relying without
such definitive guidance and policy this
recommendation grantees Iraq is a
departure from policy much more
important right thank you I'd love to
hear about it but unfortunate you have
gonna have your time
so I'm gonna have to stop you there
remembers do you have any questions
cancer Dixon
good evening the planning application as
you say is retrospective yes it's in
obviously inspect of a parking area and
under wall what was your first part it's
in respect of a parking area and a wall
yes permission to excavate indeed I must
make my question is with your local
knowledge how much of an increase in the
parking area because to me it looked as
though the past was being increased by
about 50 percent is that roughly about
right that's about my can I just explain
in 2001 the parking area was expanded to
its current size and in 2012 the agent
and the applicant both described it as a
very large substantial parking area
sufficient for the size of the extended
house they've now decided it's no longer
sufficient it's the same house thank you
okay any other questions no in that case
thank you very much very much so
make speakers are a Rogers Miranda
Rogers I believe through the agents and
they mr. Costello the applicants if
you'd like to make your way up and
between you you have six minutes are you
both going to speak or is it just
yourself and okay will you be speaking
for for six minutes okay if you if you
get close I'll give you a 30-second
warning but whenever you're ready mr.
Costello would you mind
oh you'll hear me don't worry good
evening right you will have seen from
the offices presentation that the little
house is a slightly unusual property the
house fills most of the width of its
plot immediately at the back of one edge
of a narrow road and it's only parking
area sits at the back of the other edge
the gardens extend up
from the parking area considerable slope
and downhill beyond the house to a
watercourse there's a further
considerable slope the parking area for
the little house was established many
years ago when car ownership was more
limited and the cars were a smaller size
yes it was extended in 2001 but we know
what's happened to cars in the last 20
years it's maintained or it was
maintained by a retaining wall which
holds back the garden beyond today
however it provides insufficient space
to meet the needs of the dwellings sorry
dwelling vehicles can't turn within the
site they must use the adjacent highway
which results in conflicts with
pedestrians and there is insufficient
space to accommodate the number of
vehicles associated with the house the
only option to overcome these problems
is to enlarge the parking area this
means digging out more of the bank and
creating a new retaining wall the
applicant started works at the end of
last year believing they were permitted
to development because they were
entirely within his garden only to be
told that planning permission would be
required not for the vehicles per se but
for the engineering works associated
with it digging out of the bank and the
rebuilding of the retaining wall further
into the site your case officer has
considered to the proposal and concludes
that it complies with the development
plan recommending that planning
permission should be granted subject to
conditions I can only endorse the
offices balanced assessment and the
conclusions it draws however as you've
heard there are objectors the Parish
Council and three local residents and
they identify three main issues that are
drainage
structural stability and the landscape
impact so to consider these in turn the
landscape impact the concern raised by
objectives is to the loss of trees as a
result of development and potentially
the impact on the rights it is
unfortunate that two trees were removed
they were damaged during excavation
before mr. to consult mr. Costello
realized planning permission was
required however through your
enforcement team the loss of the trees
has been appropriately resolved and new
trees will replace them there are no
further trees in the vicinity of the
wall and there will be no further harm
to the lands
your officers recommend a landscaping
condition which will enhance further the
locality you have heard there is an
objection to the application from the
Woodland Trust not natural England which
I think was also mentioned that the
proposal might reserve result in some
harm to the rides a plantation of
ancient woodland which lies adjacent to
the application site whilst it's true
the designation does lie close to the
site in practice the important woodland
is some distance away particularly at
the top of the garden rather than
adjacent to the house the air adjacent
to the house the site is planted garden
belonging in part to the applicant and
in part to his neighbor it's no longer
ancient woodland and no harm will occur
drainage the laying of additional tarmac
will reduce the permeability of the
immediate area and could result in an
increase in surface water to combat this
proposal it includes a field drain at
the bottom of the retaining wall and new
underground pipes to take water across
the road and down the side of the house
to the water course the drains are
oversized for the amount of surface
water expected however they will also
help resolve long-standing surface water
drainage issues that have resulted in
some localized flooding taking water
from this end of the road away from the
houses past the little house and down to
the brook can't see highways who has an
out now has responsibility for this road
has assessed the proposals and concludes
they are entirely acceptable and will
not result in any surface water flooding
the structural stability of the wall the
objectors have raised concern about the
structural stability of the wall
questioning whether it is adequate to
hold back the garden beyond the drawings
have been amended to address the
concerns of the objectors who said that
they weren't drawn properly in the first
instance you have heard mr. Costello has
engaged his own professional structure
engineer who did visit the site assess
and reassess the capabilities of the
wall based on her own visits and the
photographs of the appellant she
concludes that the wall is sound and
notwithstanding the comments from the
objectors there is no reason to doubt
this your officers agree with my
assessment
perhaps it's also worth noting that if
there does turn out to be a structural
issue with the wall it can be rebuilt
even higher standard and the only harm
would be to the applicants own land
temporarily and his pocket so to
conclude additional car parking is
essential to meet the needs of the
little house and improve the safety of
the adjacent road additional parking can
only be provided by digging out a bank
laying heart standing and constructing a
retaining wall the development has been
designed to respect the character
appearance of the locality additional
landscaping will mitigate any harm
resulting from the unfortunate loss of
two mature trees as a proposed wall is
structurally sound and the site does
have or will have proper drainage that
will not result in an increased risk of
flooding and if you wish to ask me about
the levels I would explain separately
the proposal accords with your
development plan and therefore I ask
that you grant planning permission in
accordance with your office's
recommendation well with any time thanks
so much
so Jenny you mentioned that two trees
were lost they're going to put two new
trees in there where else are they going
the trees that were lost were have you
got an appropriate sign okay I'm not
sure if you have one go back to the
original plan I'll do it from the
original plan sorry I'm one of the trees
is to the yes approximately
approximately where Ivan's showing you
at the moment and the other one is
approximately where Aaron is showing you
at the moment the trees aren't there
anymore so if you have pictures of the
trees I'd be quite impressed sorry these
are the trees in question one here over
here and this one here which is over
here when you're looking at the site the
two trees have since been removed
we had involvement from your enforcement
team who came out and said these two
trees look like they're going to die or
be damaged they are protected what are
you going to do about it
we took on board a professional opera
culturalist who assess it and said yes
they are unsafe and the agreement was
reached with the enforcement team to
replace it with new trees about two to
three metres away we have submitted
plans to the council and they have been
accepted that that's what we were going
to do the agreement was it will be done
September October ie during the next
planting season they haven't been done
yet because we're waiting to resolve the
planning application but obviously the
planting season extends at some time
thank you Casta Perry thank you good
evening a number of the pictures are
taken with or clearly with construction
traffic and works undertaking housing
whilst it is a retrospective application
what consideration is this construction
still going on despite the fact you
haven't got planning permission for this
that most of the construction traffic
that you're seeing is relating to
development works at the little house
itself so the planning history on this
site goes back a very long time planning
permission was granted originally back
in 2007 for extensions to the house
they've been various iterations of it
and that work is still ongoing and that
is why there is so much construction
traffic the car parking area the works
were done in part to provide somewhere
for these guys to park because that road
is so very narrow so it was done to
facilitate something very quickly in
terms of what's finished the only thing
that remains to be done is the part of
the stone cladding that goes on the
outside the rest is done together with
landscaping that will still go in and
will be subject to condition or would be
subject to condition mr. Vance
if there was a lot of talk about this
wall it wasn't a wall or wasn't built
properly presumably as it's a planning
application we'll have to go through
Building Control oh I actually don't
know the answer to that secure with that
the wall will be secure but I lost the
offices later okay thank you any other
questions
that's Adam taking away the area but the
original retaining wall that presumably
was virgin soil or least retained soil
and was permeable the new material that
you're putting in is appears to be
draining into the full drainage system
is there any intention to make that
permeable or is that just going into the
surface water drainage I'm going to pass
that to the owner his original idea was
to try and do a permeable surface but
the surface is very sickly so the
recommendation that came back from the
builders was that it would be very
difficult to create a good permeable
surface so that's why they decided to
put in a horizontal and perpendicular
drain that goes underneath the house so
all the drainage for the housing system
was already done while we were doing the
house construction and the new drainage
systems will move into that and in
addition to that we put drainage in
front of the front door of this property
but also the neighboring property
because it was some concern previously
that the neighbor's properties had
flooded and this was to alleviate that
in the future okay unless there's any
further questions thank you so much both
of you
thank you our final speaker starts and
then his counselor Mills who's been
stopped patiently at the back it's good
to see a counselor Mills so counselor
you have 30 seconds you have five
minutes
good evening committee there seems to be
a lot of irregularities in the story of
this retaining wall as for its purpose
it's telling an already large domestic
car park this is a wholly exceptional
reason for it excavating the buffer zone
of an ancient woodland where policy cs5
requires we protect our Asian woodlands
due to their scarcity the first drawings
of the war with a letter of opinion from
the structure engineer we're validated
in March the cross-section showed a war
a little less than 1.6 meters high using
ten blocks with a concrete foundation
shown below the excavator surface the
post counsel pointed out that the build
ball had 12 blocks that the concrete
foundation was cast on the surface of
the excavator ground the second version
of the story arrived in May the war was
now acknowledged to be 1.8 meters high
with 12 blocks they seemed to think that
they could cross over their matter of
the concrete foundation base it was
still shown below decks pages surface
despite a vote the photograph of the
wall which clearly shows that concrete
base above-ground making the whole wall
2.25 meters high you have to wonder how
the agent architects structure engineer
could all have missed such a large
concrete base showing above-ground the
page counts of question of foundations
again and also showed that structural
engineers calculations were inaccurate
it was not a safe design
finally in July version 3 of the ward
arrives plus structural engineers third
opinion letter and calculations these
have been presented tonight this version
that show the concrete base above the
ground as in the photos but gets what
it's almost doubled in size with a
foundation base for still below ground
Mabley they did not think there were
some more photos that showed there with
no foundation trench dug below the
shuttering on the X fated ground land
much stronger engineer was appointed to
give their opinion on a war they did not
design there have changed their mind
three times about this war they've got
calculations wrong and now they
contradict their earlier measurements of
the concrete base they made in November
it is impossible to seriously rely upon
the structure engineer's opinion and
calculations I have looked at the
submissions and calculations which the
Parish Council has provided about this
third design I have to say that I'm
concerned and extremely alarmed how this
wall has been constructed
although the wall is very thick it has
no proper footings and steel
reinforcement bars had not been spliced
together to over that by the standard
amount required I have been to this site
and this wall is holding back a steep
hill of about one in three
yep heard the structural engineer has
taken no accounts of this hill in their
calculations the scientism passable the
parcel of ground known as the terrain
ground it's soft clay and the neighbors
know it moves slowly over time this
excavation could be the tipping point he
could slip with much bigger impact
this suggests that geotechnical
investigation of the site is required he
of heard their significant concerns that
parish health and residents have about
the water drainage as explained and
demonstrated by prepared counsel this
ward is unsafe as time goes on the war
will certainly become unstable imagine
the house changes hands and the new
residents are not to wear the
bobbins the Kwanzaa consequences could
be horrendous a preowned I have to
emphasize at this wall and site needs to
be properly investigated by qualified
and experienced experts may need to draw
up proper plans to put before this
planning committee and which ensure the
site is safe if this committee prepared
to take responsibility responsibility
for approving a retrospective planning
application for a war where the players
do not resent what has been built and
the calculations presented I urge the
committee to design its intended purpose
[Laughter]
once could you turn your microphone on
please can serve on microphone off
please thank you okay so to officer
questions I think with some pretty
obvious ones that we need to address
first you've heard a number the
engineering report that we're told came
from the parish council did we actually
get an engineering report we do get
details yes in there in the parish
council representation that's on the
website so it did form it has one part
of your deliberations and we obviously
had a counter engineering report from
the applicant
how will we determine how as as our
officers have you determined which one
should carry more weight we've had a
structural engineers report from the
applicant and dated drawings that during
the course of the application the
sections have been updated in response
to the concerns that have been
and a further cite this it's been
carried out so in in this instance we've
got the full report from the engineer
and we've given other officers we've
given weight to that report but we have
had regard to other comments that have
come in regarding the construction on
the site okay
and perhaps referring us as well I just
wanted one clarity on PD rights I'm sure
you'll tell me that there are no PD
rights on the site perhaps or is there a
particular reason why this couldn't be
done on the permitted development so the
officers considered Landis garden land
but it's not being formally confirmed
through a lawful development certificate
so should the applicant wish to have
that formal determination to need to go
through that process just because it's
considered to be garden land doesn't
mean it has permitted development rights
and benefits it has been considered as
curtilage in terms of enclosures you
could enclose the land without the need
for planning permission subject to it
being less than 2 meters in height or 1
meter where it's adjacent to a highway
so that's in the officer report in terms
of enclosures can be erected but we're
considering as garden land we haven't
considered it as curtilage we're looking
at just the use of the land as garden
not whether its domestic curtilage where
you can put up outbuildings and other
enclosures without the need for planning
permission okay thank you
cancer peri first thank you chair can I
just have clarification obviously we're
here this evening from a planning
application perspective rather than
Building Control and construction so if
I'm right if we reminded to approve this
application then it would be up to
Building Control to look very carefully
at from an engineering and construction
perspective but our views this evening
or from a completely planning
perspective we are reviewing it as a
planning application
I would advise I spoke to Building
Control informally as part of this
application due to the scale of the
development it wouldn't need building
regulations it wouldn't be reassessed as
part of building regulations at a later
date it wouldn't so if there were to be
an issue in terms of its structure
what happens then so if there's if
there's liability for example safeguard
that we got
I think that's ultimately what I've
asked please don't shout outs again the
safeguard that officers have taken into
account is the qualification of the
structure engineer who's providing the
reports on behalf of the applicants and
that's the one we've given greater
weight to hence a recommendation also
chair if the wall is in the future
unsafe there are powers in the building
act for the Building Control team to
sort of serve notices to remedy a
problem if there's a threat to safety so
whilst they're not necessarily required
to once the walls completers if there
were to be a concern in the future we
can use their powers then to have that
any issue rectified if it becomes a
dangerous wall there are powers to
rectify that yeah okay all right thank
you
councillor Jennings sorry about all the
different processes and simplest thing
it wouldn't widen anyone just dubba take
a couple of hours to dig a hole to have
any foundation is there seems it's
strange to me I'm going to assume that
that hasn't happened well that you're
not aware that that's happened we're
considering on the information provided
and it's an applicant structural report
that we're having given weight to his
officers okay thank you
councillor bonds you did indicate
earlier and do you still have a question
or you've been satisfied well I think
we're come into a clear position of the
wall and statistics on respect of who's
going to look after it so it sounds like
yourself okay
counsel Adam did you have a question it
was regarding the permeability of the
that has been revealed and whether there
is anything within the planning guidance
towards the requirement obviously we had
the comment from the during the course
of the application and warrick to Canada
Council Highways Authority has confirmed
that this now forms part of the adopted
highway which means there the Consul T
responsible for drainage on this parcel
of land here going through the center of
the site we've consulted them as a
council T during the course of the
application and they've raised no
objection to the drainage proposed and
set out on this plan subject to a
condition to ensure it's in accordance
with the details and so there the Consul
T we're looking to for drainage in
relation to this application but just to
pick up on your point about permeability
planning policy does encourage permeable
surfaces a sustainable urban drainage
systems however in this case is you
heard from the applicant that was
impossible but it was attempted okay
members any further questions from you
no signals cancel Mills I'm gonna invite
you up but it has to be a matter of
facts that you're introducing do we have
overlooked Thank You Jeremy it's just to
reiterate that it is a fact that this
[Music]
[Applause]
the opinion of the structure is changed
three times and which is their right
which is the correct decision and also
it's talking about building controls it
could be too late I mean if it all
collapses okay I think those are more
comments and observations on your part
of in fact you've took 20 seconds I do
need to ask the applicant if they want
to make any response to that don't feel
obliged to but I do want to get to 20
seconds placed in the interest of
fairness yeah we've had a structural
engineer do the report there's been
various reports come back from the
parish council unnamed unqualified with
regard to the assessment the only
quality
assessment is reports that we put
forward the rest is is opinions from my
perspective thank you
do we have any further questions for
officers at this point no debate who
would like to start counselor Adam I'd
like to point out at this point that I
am a qualified structural engineer and I
based on my professional experience
would suggest that embedding a
foundation within established ground
does provide an active part of
resistance in determining earth
retaining structures the photographs
I've seen from sites do give me cause
for concern the critical nature of that
I wouldn't be able to put towards this
committee at this time because I would
have to based on my professional
background carry out calculations to to
make that decision but I wouldn't say in
good conscience that I could support a
retrospective approval of that structure
as shown I do appreciate that this
committee is looking at planning matters
not necessarily in construction matters
but given the implications that Building
Control might have on that I think
that's a real concern I must say that
the wider issues of planning I've
generally been satisfied by in terms of
things like drainage and the extent of
the development and the appearance of
the wall of the the structure does
concern me and I won't support the
application on that basis so just just
so I'm absolutely clear the principle of
what's been proposed you're comfortable
with but based on the images you've seen
from a construction perspective and your
background and experience you have
concern although you have quite clearly
stated that is purely based on pictures
you haven't assessed it formally
yes no I died but I would say that if I
were to put my reputation and profession
on it I want to do a lot I want to do
more professional calculation
investigation in other strugglers has
built I think I would expect you to do
that
it's very difficult that I'm actually a
qualified engineer myself albeit not
construction and I wouldn't be happy
making a desperate judgment on a series
of pictures that I haven't taken other
members would you like to contribute to
the debate before I start picking on
people councillor Jennings would you
like to speak no you don't feel obliged
might phone on please I think the whole
thing would be very simple a couple of
hours I don't know why anyone hasn't
done this the whole process okay cancer
Perry I'm sitting on this committee with
no engineering qualifications whatsoever
but what we're looking at is a planning
application and that is on the basis
that we have come forward to look at
this we have by all accounts as
structural engineers report from someone
who is highly qualified we have our own
Building Control team my view would be
if there's any conditions that we can
add to just support and lay any any of
the concerns we have but I would be
minded from a purely planning
perspective to go with the officers
recommendation because I have no
material planning reasons to refuse it
based on planning Thank You councillor
and kasib answered you signal in
planning terms I think we're in a
difficult situation
I'm just every other construction in
planning we have a construction plan we
have
the movements what we're going to do so
I think if we can improve the situation
out there with the wall the construction
and all the other things with some
conditions I think that to me is the way
forward okay counselor Jennings and
they'll have something to say can
Saban's need any microphone off please
thank you can you put a condition on
there to get them to check it and so
while you were what our members were
debating then I was checking on that and
the simple answer is no what week and
and based on the what I'm sensing from
the committee is that you're on you
appear to be comfortable with the
principle of the development but
uncomfortable with what actually been
developed that make sense the physical
form we have a choice we can either on
the basis of that this is a planning
decision that we're making make the
decision to grant planning and that's it
because we cannot make decisions on the
structural integrity of something an
alternative is that we can defer subject
to a an independent civil engineer and
checking the structural soundness of the
what's been put forward now and subject
to that then come back for a decision to
be made how does everyone feel about
that councillor Dickson is there a third
alternative that we possibly approve it
and add a note as opposed to a condition
suggesting such action I mean I guess
that's kind of option one that we
approve it and I don't know yes we could
do that but we have no way of enforcing
that that check and I sense from what
members are saying is that they're
uncomfortable in granting something that
they're not that they're not comfortable
with but something physical could
as a result of our granting those are
those are the options as I see them I'm
happy to hear any further options you
may have councillor Barnes if we were to
further the application for a better
report on that would be delegated
approval I don't I don't think unless we
unless we say we approved subject to
confirmation of an engineering report
but perhaps our planning manager can
tell me otherwise
I mean it's within your gift is a
committee to decide what level of
delegation you want to give the results
of that independent survey you can
choose to delegate it to officers to
their satisfaction or if it's a greater
concern to you you can decide that you
want the results of that brought back to
this committee we have a third option we
can grant subject to an independent
civil engineering
kept my phrase which is all wrong it's
totally long with I apologize subject to
a report from about confirming that the
engineering is sound that is an option
to us as well if you're happy to go
along those lines and it seems that
people are I do need counsel Vance has
proposed that it's been seconded by
Councillor Chen and I'll check it in the
circumstance that it isn't planned to be
sound that it's brought back to this
committee or do officers refuse it under
delegated authority with the backup of
the independent surveyor the only reason
we are concerned so delegation is the
only way forward yeah I think that's I
think that's fair okay
yep allegation everyone happy okay do we
have a second that we didn't win cancer
Jennings thank you so much so can we
have a show of hands for the proposal as
we've just put that is unanimous
bless in that case I think I forgot to
say this now it will resolve to grant
subject to an approved independent
engineering report fabulous and I think
actually we've been going for just over
two hours I think it's only fair that we
had to take a very quick comfort break
so literally two minutes and we'll be
back in here so 19 minutes past on my
watch
c2b I would be grateful our next
application is application 1900 8:04
very this is land adjacent to church
bank in Welford on Aven are presenting
officer Esther classy strip over to you
Thank You chairman this proposal is
seeking a variation of condition 2 of
Planning Commission reference 18 4 /
double 0 8 9 2 4 / very this approval
was issued on the 14th of June 2018 and
it's a variation of an original plan
Commission issued in November 2015 for
the erection of two dwellings the
variation the subject of this
application seeks to amend the layout of
one of the to approve dwellings labeled
plot 2 on the northernmost part of the
site this application site is within an
area of open countryside outside of the
Beltway boundary of Welford to the east
of bintang Road and in close proximity
to the river
Aven as you can see there as indicated
on the black dots here is some satellite
imagery showing the application site
here we have a proposed layouts and site
plan showing occurs here so this is plot
number 2 here the subject of this
variation there is also a plot one here
title which has no amendments proposed
as part of this application here we see
the proposed front and side elevations
of plot number two here we have the
approved elevations of plot two we can
then see the proposed rear and site to
the subject of this application again
that's the rear and side of what has
been approved previously for this
specific dwelling so I'll go back to the
other one again so they proposed
approved
and then for the rear inside a proposed
and approved got some photos now of the
site itself here we have stood at the
entry point of the access drive the plot
to looking northeast woods one can see
the gates here the XS drive also for the
gates for the closest neighboring
dwelling river lodge here we are now
stood on the site itself looking
northeast towards towards where plot two
was will be sited here and looking
downslope one can obviously alter the
proximity of the River Avon here we're
now stood in the same spot looking back
up the hill towards Church Bank and
sighted next to a boundary hedge which
divides this application site with River
Lodge here we now have what is a Google
Street View image of what the view is
from Ludington rows a road in relative
close proximity I've tried my best to
actually signify I hope it's partly
clear actually where we are my photos
where I was just stood were
approximately here on where the cursor
is and this is the plot big sense of the
application sites on this hill with the
River Avon in between these two slopes
here the principle of this dwelling and
indeed the other one also has already
been accepted on this site it is
considered that this variation of
condition 2 would not result in a
material or additional harm to the
amenity of neighboring properties would
not alter the overall visual impacts of
the development or the general character
of the landscape chairman the
recommendation is to grant this
application for the reasons that felt
pages 80 of your agenda thank you thank
you very much speak on this item is
counselor son Carter from of the Parish
Council
giveme kalsekar see you'd been him many
times before so you know I know seconds
notable good evening councilors although
this application on the face of it is a
simple variation it is in fact the fifth
variation to the original application in
2015 and shows a great example of
creeping development each changes seems
simple but in aggregate it's too much
and actually if this application was
presented today it'd be refused on the
grounds of its outside the built of area
boundary it's visual impact on the open
countryside and the housing mix and type
it is a 6,000 square foot house and it's
actually in effect one to mirror so you
end up with in a state type look
actually when you look at that picture
that was shown earlier and clearly it's
contrary to Welford on Aven Neighborhood
Development Plan 85 the visual impact of
this will be significant we have
accepted that actually this development
will take place so we've actually
supported some of this in the past but
increasing the size of these properties
actually is definitely going to be very
very impactful from not only the
Ludington row but also the b43 now and
as you drive from Stratford to Biddeford
so it will severely impact the rural
setting it's all we ask in a way is that
you actually look at this a little bit
of fresh and actually go back to 2015
and say if this application came in
today would I support it and the answer
to that clearly in policy terms from SDC
and from the parish council would be no
so we would ask that you refuse this and
keep a little bit of variety in the
design of these houses having said all
that the additional there's an
additional issue here that the SIL
documentary should actually has been
incorrectly completed SIL is payable on
this development for some reason hasn't
been picked up the increase in square
meter age is 125 sills should be payable
in
100 or more however for some reason
actually this hasn't actually been
picked up and we can't work out why Syl
isn't payable on this application and
clearly SDC you know you guys and girls
need the money the civil money to
develop the area and also we do as well
for you know buses for local elderly
people with visa support and all that
sort of stuff so if you are minded to do
it make sure that SIL is payable equally
of course our position is that this is
you know in an appropriate development
it's too big to visible and we'd like
the variety thank you Marcus thank you
it's very rare that we say no to money
but on a serious note we will check that
sell things shortly members do we have a
any questions counsel Dixon
good evening you mentioned that it's in
contravention to the Neighborhood
Development Plan yes is that
specifically in relation to open
countryside the s85 yes it is any other
questions no very good thank you very
much so our next speaker is a Martin
Walker the agent good evening welcome I
think you've got a good idea of how
things are gonna work so three minutes
when you're ready and I'll give you a
30-second warning okay the just to start
off very clearly the footprint of plot
two is now proposed to be 6040 five
square feet
compared to plot one which is slightly
larger at 6096 to give you an idea of
the setting of this plot Church Bank the
immediately adjacent property has an
area of seven thousand and six hundred
square feet River Lodge which is very
close by is a very very substantial
property I don't know
with his it's very large the proper one
rich height is 450 point 3 meters above
ordinance datum and the highest point of
plot 2 Ridge is 49 point seven five
which is what it was always going to be
now in fact we had some initial feedback
through the planning office in on the
basis of the parish councils comments
that it was in danger of being too big
too linear to substantial so we have
stepped the south wing down to be at a
level of forty eight point two five so
we've got a central element building
steps down and actually I'm quite
pleased about it because this now
follows the lie of the land much more
closely and sits into the landscape very
well to give you an idea of the level of
these properties the highest part of
what too is at forty nine point seven
five the road in the background is at a
height of 50 to 52 meters above datum so
about three meters above and Church Bank
the ridge of that the very large
property that we saw in the photograph
or you could just about this urn in the
photograph is that about fifty nine and
in the last year or so some properties
have been completed in church Bank with
a rich height of over sixty meters so
our efforts to hide this cut it into the
bank are considerable and it will be
much less visible on the landscape than
the existing properties that surround it
the separation between plot one and plot
two will be twenty two to twenty three
meters which is about the size of the
buildings and we've got extensive tree
landscaping between them as you can see
the materials originally for plot two
were going to be brick and timber which
was the same as plot one again on the
basis of comments from the parish
council and the planning officer we
changed that to be
the local Benton stone on the lower part
of the timber above to give some more
interest and give it a slightly softer
feel 30 seconds
I'd like to just sum up and say we've
made considerable efforts to make this a
very sympathetic scheme it is a very
attractive scheme it is very much in the
proportions of the area or slightly
smaller and will be way below the
horizon unlike some of the recently
constructed properties in the area and
interestingly the people who may have
possibly seen it would be loath
Ludington parish council who have made
no objection has happened none of the
neighbors it will not be visible from
relford thank you very much if we go
anyone you might have some questions I
think you do so please take the seats
make yourself comfortable thank you good
evening in terms of cell is this being
put forward as a self-build application
and is that why still doesn't apply or
hasn't has not come forward perhaps will
we might well cover that in
clarification from offices no in that
case this time thank you very much mr.
Walker you're free to go councillor
Barnes is next up one of this
kasib answer thank you for your input
now we'll go to questions too often 5
minutes 30 seconds when you ready turn
your microphone on please we have seven
applications in open countryside in 2015
that we obviously couldn't depose them
for the simple reason was you hadn't got
a parish plan no fatherland
[Music]
I suppose seven more houses in Welford
that we didn't want as you can see some
of them ones on the top of the ridge
have been built and the only people that
can actually see them are Livington
Ludington Road is not far away across
the river as you can see from where you
are now
Lincoln has had a number of suggestions
to make them more or better hit open
countryside and one or two people have
done the same thing but one or two
haven't there in this respect this one
is done
off the top of the ridge on the bank top
the floodplain and Benton Parish big
stone was requested by Ludington barrel
council and various other changes
because they thought the two houses
looked very similar and in open
countryside they wouldn't look
attractive the River navigation people
were at the meeting as well and they
were concerned about houses I said well
we can't stop
and they also thought that they need to
be both distinctive but different they
are an open countryside we can't do
anything about us and every time we've
asked the applicant from the Paris to do
things they do it we come to this
situation now where I support the
application I think it's the best we've
got
it's not too high in the right place and
it looks different to the other he's big
but looking for where it is you can see
those thousands on the top there they're
all four and five bedroom houses coiled
up as you ask any technical questions
but it is in a Dilek spot right by the
river open countryside in the Haven
Valley and I feel that it's okay thank
you guys once does anyone have any
questions technical or otherwise where
comes the ones No thank you very much so
we move now to our questions to our
offices please I think the first
important one we need to address is cell
whilst it's not a planning consideration
in terms of approved or otherwise my
understanding is black and white so we
see the payable or not could you give us
some clarity of it whether it is or
isn't in this instance some of the
development floor space was granted
prior to sell so Scylla isn't payable on
that floor space however this proposes
an increase of 95 square meters over and
above previous approvals therefore sales
payable on that amount so as per page 79
of your report it's seven thousand one
hundred and forty seven pounds and eight
depends
marvelous thank you members do you have
any other questions for officers it's
worth just saying unless an exemption
applies cuz with SIL
there are certain exemptions you don't
always have to pay it I'm assuming from
that it's not exempt but there we are
in that case let's move to the debates
anyone want to start
that's a Dixon yes I think we simply cut
to the chase mr. Chairman I should
propose that we should grant his
recommendation there eased with there's
no prob with the desire council problem
with the design I see the second day
marvelous thank you very much does
anyone else would have anything abstain
no in that case that's moved to the vote
so the proposal to grant in London's
Officer recommendation show hands please
in that case committee resolves to grant
application 1900 8:04 very let's move
now to our next item which is two items
in fact we will here on block 1901 8 8 0
ful and 1901 8 8 1 lb seizes Bassets
cottage in Ellington are presenting
officer shirt whenever you're ready
right Thank You chairman this proposal
is seeking full and listed building
consent for the demolition of 20th
century additions and addition of a new
porch and rear extension conversion
restoration of bothy on a dwelling in
Ellington Basset cottage on back streets
there are separate listed building
consent additionally which is seeking
addition of roof lights and repair to
brickwork the pointing of the and and
more of the cottage itself this black
dot signifies the site's location within
the village of Burlington
here we see the application site
outlined in red the red boundary one can
see the application is greatly listed by
virtue of the we're here basically the
dwelling it's illustrated by the block
red to show that it's great to listed
one can also see here there is a grade 1
listed church that mary's church this
plan also shows we are entirely within a
conservation area in addition here we
see some existing floor plans including
what is termed a detached bothy both the
outbuilding here here we have existing
elevational detail here we have proposed
floor plans and a breakdown of works
that are proposed as part of both this
full and listed building consent
here we see some proposed elevations
detailing the addition of a porch here
to the front and other works in listen
to a real extension here
to the rear
that's all so just go back there's also
this this is the outbuilding essentially
the subject of a proposed conversion
into use of by the dwelling in addition
here we see the front of the dwelling
one can see also a prominent silver
birch tree here sited in the front
garden here we are looking at the same
frontage again but from a further
vantage point where we can also then see
a gate that feeds into grounds for the
st. Mary's great one listed Church here
we are still in the garden looking
westwards towards the rear of the
dwelling this built form here on the
right my cursor here hopefully that's
clear that's in separate ownership the
red line includes this property here
which is the subject of this application
applications here we are now looking at
a closer rear elevation to show what
would be proposed to be removed
including this flat roof - element here
here we are now stood at the rear of the
neighboring property brown beaches one
can see a neighboring habitable window
sited here that overlooks the proposed
development here we are now stood in the
cemetery of the church viewing bassett
cottage here we are stood in the fields
and grounds to the rear of the
application site on the left here and
then separately on a what is a footpath
behind looking at our application
property here here we have a closer view
of the rear elevation with a greater
appreciation of the proximity of the
grade 1 listed church which is here here
we have a submitted indicative CGI
imagery of what the proposed rear
extension would look like here we then
see that same indicative CGI from a
further distance in the grounds
of the church there is identified
substantial harm to the unique historic
character of the Great Sea listed
building the setting of the grade 1
listed church and separate harm
identified to the conservation area
there are separate concerns from an
overbearing and lots of a menace to
perspective for neighboring amenity at
the brand breaches property additional
technical concerns have been raised on
ecology and concerns over the impact of
the development on the tree to the
frontage chairman it's for these reasons
that the recommendation is to refuse
both the full and listed building
consent for the reasons detailed in
pages 89 and 90 of your agendas thank
you thank you very much for that our
first speaker tonight is councillor Joel
Osborne from element and parish council
good evening mr. Osborne councillors
Blanchard saying so if there's a laying
wait no I'm glad to hear it you have
three minutes I'll give you 30 seconds
okay whenever you're ready please thank
you very much chairman I'm here tonight
to represent the views of the filming
tanana's console on the applications
relating to Basset cottage the last
major work undertaken to Basset cottage
was in the 1970s which was prior to its
listing today we be properly regard that
work to be insensitive to the historic
character of the building with the
installation of modern components and
the construction of a poorly designed
single-story extension at the rear since
that time little maintenance of the
building has been undertaken and the
fabric of the building has deteriorated
significantly the residents of Arlington
are fortunate to live within a
conservation area with 40 listed
buildings in the village the parish
council takes its obligations to support
the conservation of this body of Herot
heritage assets
however we are guided by the
consideration that conservation does not
always equate to preservation but is
sometimes the careful management of
change we seek to ensure that changes
proposed enhance the appearance of the
village and supported as a thriving
community not necessarily as a museum
piece planning policy guideline 15 in
1996 stated many listed buildings can
sustain some degree of sensitive
alteration or extension to accommodate
continuing or new uses the Parish
Council considers that these proposals
do so in particular they remove the
previous poor quality changes to the
listed building they retain historic
details whilst undertaking the essential
restoration of a structure which is in
progressive decline they provide an
extension which is of high quality and
masks an inappropriate modern extension
next door of which there's been little
any officers report they retain the
bothy the historic feature which is in
grave danger of falling down and put it
back into use Ellington Parish Council
have no hesitation in commending these
proposals to you and cordially request
that you consent to the applications
thank you thank you very much okay thank
you very much for thank you contribution
our next speaker is mr. Spicer again
welcome back
I hope you found tonight as interesting
as mr. Osborn's naturally so you have
three minutes as you know I'll give you
a start we've got a slide show thank you
thank you unusual job tonight of
providing you with facts and correct
information on the property which in
some instances differs from the
conservation officers report in image 1
on the top left-hand side there you will
see the port which was proposed and
installed in 1977 on image 2 you'll see
the top right hand window in the
officers in concept the conservation
officers report she notes this to be
harmful to be removed because if its
historic nature there was a 15 meter one
a story building which covered that
window there was no window there pre
1977 so the historic nature is fairly
new
the view from number three the bothy
which is the poor condition and is
literally falling down at the moment is
in need of renovation image is four and
five illustrates a modern steel beam and
a steel post which is encased in the
past aboard column structure which
supports the floor which is partially
falling down
we provided structural
details which remove these and provide a
more sympathetic solution to that images
six and seven illustrates the modern
staircase from just after 1977 under
London conservation officers analysis as
a historic part of the building and
cannot really be replaced without harm
the images in a tower were chimneys been
removed by somebody previously and their
chimney above is unsupported and unsafe
we're looking to replace these areas
with a modern insertion which is
reflective of their time it's of a high
quality and will ensure that this
building it's fit for the 21st century
if you go to the next slide this is a
combination and it's a couple of slides
just to give you a historic analysis of
the cottage on the left-hand side that's
the ground floor plan pre nineteen
seventy seven you'll see the large 15
metre deep extension which covered the
window I explained moment ago that
appeared post then and has been
illustrated as being a historic element
our proposals on the far right-hand side
and the proposals in the center were
just post in 1977 when you see the
single-story kitchen appeared to the
back if you go to the next slide you'll
see here now we're proposing to demolish
the kitchen extension have impaired the
bothy and create a lightweight
high-quality extension we're also
looking to close off the window which
appeared in 1977 30 seconds if I could
ask you to go to the Fond slide please
there's an illustration here of the
front elevation as existing on the left
and as proposed on the right you will
see the improvements we're looking to do
and on the bottom you'll see the
existing elevation from the public view
on the left and the montage on the right
the proposals are to significantly
improve an existing building in very
poor condition and we feel that these
facts offer you the opportunity to make
your own balanced decision in terms
the conservation of this building and
maybe in your own view two pipes in this
one occasion go get your offices and
support the application thank you very
much thank you ever so much
moments do we have any questions cancer
pairing thank you hello again I just
wonder whether you can by noting the
committee report that detailed
pre-application advice was sought and
with the conservation officer and that
an almost identical application was then
subsequently was drawn in June can you
explain why you know if it was almost
identical to the one following
pre-application advice the reasons for
then putting forward this one that was
similar to the one before course scan so
we made a pre-application device and
that verbal response from the
conservation officer site is it we then
made for application the initial
application that was notice been
withdrawn during application the
conservation officer made an initial
assessment on the listing of the
property in the conservation area she
also suggested that if you in the report
there's no objection raised to the
conversion in principle there's no
objection to contemporary design in fact
is supported however she raised in the
initial application that was she found
that wasn't enough detail from the
structural engineer in terms of how
we're going to deal with the staircase
how we're going to deal with the chimney
and the steel implications and the
living room so we would do the
application we went away with additional
more technical detail and design point
in structural engineering evidence
assessment provided that information
that was submitted as part of the
application before yourself today Thank
You members any other questions for mr.
Spicer counselor Barnes
refusal there's a window were looking
and window could you explain that and if
I could ask the officer to go to a
photograph that you showed from the
churchyard in your proposal there was if
there was a photograph of the window I
think you raised it and that's the one
that so our application proposes a
two-story extension but through
contemporary style the roofs are
maintained to be just at the eaves level
so on the photograph there you can see
there's a gutter you just use a very
small amount of gutter on the property
the window in question you can see it's
visible that particular property has a
one and a half story extension which is
to fall length of its garden in terms of
amenity space and protection the way
that the offices learn level with them
they initially take a 45 degree angle
from that window if anything impedes it
at that stage they take a 25 degree
angle if that's any issues with that you
can do a viscosity analysis given the
height that we're at were way way below
what would be impactful and therefore
isn't it seem to be necessary okay thank
you
and that's there any other questions so
don't think there are thank you very
much
so we're now able to officers we have no
we have no award member head speaks
we're over to officers questions does
anyone have any questions for
clarification with the officers
counselor Jennings so check out of there
been any objections from the neighbors
no there's no neighbor objections okay
any other questions
no and they face this oh not to debate
who like starts cuz Laban's wanna start
along with the officers recommendation
but after hearing the applicant and the
base counsel I think I need to think
again the window and the light is to
certain extent marginal sometimes new
and old do go together and we do want me
to say what is now a listed building
which wasn't before so as far as I'm
concerned I can't approve what is being
put forward by the officers but would be
happy to grant with some serious
conditions it's a proposal to go with
the officers recommendation Thank You
councillor Parekh Thank You chair
obviously we have a number of
applications that come forward and we
have here tonight's application with a
very detailed response from the
conservation officer quite often it
comes forward with an objection my
concern here is I would actually have no
objection to the principle of
development on this particular site but
my concerns are the scale and the size
of the extension that's actually
proposed which is reinforced I believe
by
conservation putting the word
significant in front of objection I I
understand and I totally have sympathies
with the applicant because obviously
there is some building works that needs
to be done to be to bring to make better
use of the property particularly with
the the outbuilding that is in a bad
state of repair but my views are that I
feel this just takes it a bit too far
which does take it out of character with
neighboring properties and it would have
in its present form I feel it would have
a major impact on the grade 1 listed
church by would rather see this come
back with us with a one-story extension
rather than two-story at the back and
therefore I am compelled to go in line
with the officers recommendation but
it's not I just feel it's over to over
it's the scale and the size and there is
an impact in this very precious and very
special village just one clear is that a
you seconding councillor Martha's
proposal I would propose that we follow
the officers recommendation because I
find that is just whilst I can
understand the need to enhance the
property I just think that counts for
Perry that is just too much too much
glass and it needs to be more
sympathetic to the conservation area the
listed building if that was put up us
would personally say that the listed
building permission should be withdrawn
completely with councillor Perry's
summary I think it does just go a bit
too far and that the the degradation of
the the current buildings on site is an
issue for the not necessary water that
needs to be considered by this
application and the proposed extension
is just out of keeping and not
appropriate
okay council Jennings um I think he
looks great
but I can obviously from the point of
the from the church I'm not quite sure
what I'd love to be able to see a
picture from the church again towards
the back of the property you haven't got
one with the CGI from the church what as
to what it would look like there's not
from the church would it make it all in
the way so will it make a material
difference to your decision-making
tonight well I think yes because it's to
do with to do with the chair it's really
okay that's when the church
okay do you have you got more you'd like
to add to the debate at this point I'd
like to second causes problem okay so
let's just recap on what's happened to
it so we have a propose to grant and
that's been seconded we are looking to
grant against off as a recommendation
and this is on an LBC so we have to take
each application individually so we're
looking at the fault start with I need
to understand from you both what your
reasons are for going against the
officers recommendation you were the
first to make the proposed also we have
to hear this first can you give me your
reasons for going against the officers
recommendation in this instance both
math it's not as great as the original
building its safeguarded in a listed
building I did go on site the other day
and he's all he's tidying up around
there to be honest and in the respect of
the visual effect on the listed
buildings I don't think they will be too
great okay I'm gonna need read because
it you'll be aware there's four reasons
for refusing planning permission
recommended I'm going to need some
reasons on each of the four to overcome
that the one that I've had relates to
the listed building as part of the
assessment is necessary to decide what
level of harm there is and then
dependent on what level of harm there is
whether there's any public benefits so
that's the balancing exercise you need
to do in order to decide if that's your
decision that it's acceptable to grant
the extension in listed building terms
but I would remind you there's three
other reasons one in terms of neighbor
immunity one with the lack of a bat
survey
the lack of a tree survey so I'd be
grateful for any comments on those
reasons are overcome yelling chicken
first good conditions in about probably
about survey done and tree survey so
you're saying the reasons you've given
you've prepared to grant subject to
about serve in a tree survey what are
you expecting that bat serve entry
survey to status to prove feet in order
for you to be happy okay
sounds of answer do you want to say
something well we know every house in my
area has to have a bat or a bird box
every new house and this could be the
same okay just bear with me for a second
I'm just going to take some advice first
have different size holes for different
animals
in terms of the listed building reason
I'm still not clear whether members are
saying that there's no harm and
therefore they don't need to find any
public benefits or whether there's some
harm and there are public benefits
that's what I'm going to need as a
reason I'm not passing comment either
way I'm just saying that's the process
that you need to go through Thunder the
listed buildings act
there's the neighboring issue which I as
I said I just need some comment on the
bat survey point I can understand the
comment that it could be conditioned the
reason it is required prior to
determination is because the nature of
what bat species may be there could
influence define the design of the
building because different bats have
different requirements and may need a
change of design which would change the
application that's why it needs to be
done prior to determination not prior to
commencement and the tree survey point
without that information effectively
grant and the permission may mean that
the tree is lost before knowing what its
value is what its life expectancies and
all those things thank you does that
help you that you want to speak
constitutionally I hang on I might be I
did seek legal guidance I'm gonna get
some more apparently hang on so you can
thank and for this she has found little
nuance and a little bit of wording so
please do come up and you can give us
your good point of clarity and point of
fact the officer
for you to accept it at the same time as
a team as motion so I was accepted but
it has been done by and of course what
with wildlife services and there is no
issues with bats whatsoever
did you have a tree to save a dime a
tree the tree falls a tree works were
undertaken if you go to your report
silver birch tree at the front was under
application there was there was a tree
and application to modify three silver
sheet from 1900 173 tree yes 100 page 86
yes in history work would have taken to
that to the facilitator words the
driveway I'm gonna okay thank you
I guess that poses the question that
we've been informed that you have had a
tree survey and about survey but they've
not been accepted could you please
enlighten us it what why if that is the
case and what's received
with regards the the bat survey I can't
give a reason why it's not been accepted
I suspect it would have taken the
application out time but I can't be sure
on that point with regard to the tree
works what you've been told about is a
proposal to lift the crown and do other
works to it
however the prosper the officers report
the reason proof usual is insufficient
information again that's not to say that
it might be acceptable but there was a
risk of harm to the tree without that
information in order to inform the
decision so it's effectively a holding
reason okay well I guess we've got
series of options here we obviously
would have a proposed in a seconder for
both granting and the reasons that
you've given for that we have a proposal
a seconder for refusing and the reason
is that the committee report if members
were minded to we could defer pending in
further information on the tree report
and the bat report and then defer
pending information on the tree report
and the bat report and then make a
decision at a later date my gut feel is
that we don't think we should be
deferring at this point I need from in
my mind I want absolute clarity and
surety from those proposing to grant
that their reasons are strong enough to
go against the clear steer that we've
had from our officers but it's entirely
in your gift are you I am not proposing
a deferment if you guys wanted to do
that by all means do you have to go to
vote on grant that's you put to refuse
to grant yes okay right so
hang on hang on hang on in order to do
that we have to be absolutely clear that
the officers is satisfied
your reasons are sound are they are you
happy that the reasons given are sound
in order for us to progress to a vote
yes I've got enough on the tree survey I
understand what members have said on the
bat survey I still haven't had comment
on the the outlook to the neighbor at
brown beaches so as I said I'd
appreciate just to steer on that because
by law you're obliged to give reasons
for going against officers the key one
for me and I've said this previously is
there was a clear process that in law as
to how to assess the impact on the list
of building decide the level of harm and
once you've decided that are the public
benefits and at the moment I don't know
which of those two you looking at are
you saying there's no harm therefore we
don't need public benefits are you
saying there's some level of harm and
you've found some public benefits okay
and therefore the public benefits to out
like that would be limited as well
what are those public benefits say
councillor Barnes please we have to be
absolutely clear that the reasons that
have been given are reasons for refusal
we need to be clear and this is a legal
requirement so the reasons why you think
they those are overcome so far we appear
to have had a there is harm but is
limited so the public benefits of that
are to outweigh I'm assuming that your
public benefits are the reinstatement of
the
is it both your boothy bothy and the
general improvements to the property and
the view therefore off the property are
you satisfied that that is your position
yes now on reason number two which is
the overlooking overbearing from the
neighboring window can you give me a
reason as to why you think that isn't an
issue that's a reason to overcome the
applicant to a certain extent that's why
I asked him the question didn't agree
with the opposition recommendation of
the 45 and the 25 degrees kidding so
ultimately you're saying that you don't
agree with that because they don't fit
in without 45 20 whatever it is degrees
well we have had a different opinion
when I asked the question to the
applicant to what the opposite of say no
right but
so therefore the levels of light to that
neighboring window your content would be
acceptable okay okay we've got that all
right so let's have it let's move now to
a vote on granting permission based on
what has just been put forward I have a
show of hands of those that want to
grant to Chairman those games so that
motion is not upheld so we have a
proposal to refuse in line with the
officers recommendation I think from
memory that was cancer Dixon supported
by councillor Perry I think the other
way around I think it was sorry my
apologies it was the other way around I
think wait to that vote so could I have
a show of hands for those looking to
refuse sweet German and those against
two chairmen and abstentions one
chairman
okay so committee have therefore
resolved to refuse planning application
1901 eight
eight-zero ful in line with the offers a
recommendation now we also need to look
at the LBC so could I please have a
proposal for either granting or refusing
at the LBC counselor pairing chair happy
to propose that we refuse LBC thank you
Casa Dixon fabulous I'm going to assume
automatically that it is in line with
your commendation and the reasons that
he has put so could we please have a
show of hands who are prepared to refuse
the LBC two three against and abstention
two three okay so in that case we're
committee has resolved to refused
permission for 1901 881 LP see jumpin
thank you very much
we will now then move to our next
application okay apologies we have just
gone over three hours we have two
applications left they are waterside as
Jeff Navin and The Grange in south and
please could I have a vote that you're
prepared to carry on and finish those
last two show of hands please
with these I gotta say that we have got
12 bats because I think we have
no I think we get so 1902 one to one ful
14 Waterside we have any flutes to to us
Thank You chairman the application site
which is denoted by the black dot in the
center of the plan is located in
stratford-upon-avon Town Center
Conservation Area and has always said
within the red zone the site prints onto
waterside at first floor the building is
not listed but nearby listed buildings
are identified in red and the
application site is just here which is
edged red so um for planning permission
is sought for the change of use from a
community used for a residential
dwelling there would be no external
changes to facilitate the change of use
this phase who is taking looking in a
westerly direction from waterside the
part of the building subject to the
change abuse is the first law top right
now the rear access to the application
site can be seen which is just here and
the principle of a single dwelling is
accepted on this site because it falls
from the stratford-upon-avon to the
superior boundary and site-specific
issues regarding flood risk impact on
heritage assets and immunity are all
acceptable it is therefore recommended
that planning permission is granted as
set out in the report thank you
Amy thank you very much we have zero
speakers so would anyone like to make
points of clarification to the officer
cancer bands that's not the points of
clarification
because the man that drew the picture is
here I'll just clarify how our internal
architect was that produce that
wonderful item it's not okay let's move
to the debate then who would like to
start the debate or make it propose I
don't mind which cancer Dixon
recommendation Thank You councillor
Jenny thank you very much chef hands
please grant application 1902 one to one
ful thank you very much okay so on to
our next one which is application 1901
949 ful this is the range in South and
our presenting opposite is Erin
Fetherston
own if you can beat that a four-time
Punk shall be impressed the application
sight line to the north of salvan
settlement and identify it by the
blacktop on this plan we'd advise it the
council is the landowner and applicant
for this application this slide shows
the application site outlined in red on
the plan site lines within the built-up
area boundary and conservation area of
this album site includes two buildings
including the grains located east of the
site here which is a great unit of
building and has an office use Grange
Hall is located to the west of the site
and it uses a community center to the
south of the site is a piece garden who
is an existing vehicle access with an in
and out exit onto the Coventry Road to
the east of the site neighboring
properties lie to the north the west and
the south this slide shows an aerial
image of the site outlined in red the
grain can be seen to the right of the
image here and the Grange Hall to the
left of the image the existing internal
access road is visible on the slide you
see the entrance coming in here ground
and it goes underneath the building here
and you can come back out exit onto the
road or Coventry Road here and there is
a car park
access through this area here site
contains 66 individual trees eight of
which category a 16 category B and 50 to
category C trees you can see the tree
coverage across the site and deceased
Planning Commission is sought for
engineering operations to enlarge
existing access points onto the Coventry
Road to allow vehicles to pass but by
each other side this will enable access
to be provided for each individual
building to the gray area shown on this
plan we've seen here here an internal
enlargement is proposed here as well to
allow vehicles to pass and it means that
you can have entry and exit through one
access serving this building to the east
and entry exit to the south serving the
building to the west of the site this
plan gives an indication of how the
parking spaces may be allocated this
photograph was taken from the Coventry
Road looking south toward the site see
the tree coverage here and you can see
dis here the entrance point this slide
shows the alteration to the existing
vehicle entrance you can see the
enlargement so proposed to allow other
vehicles to pass you can see the vehicle
movement there first photograph was
taken from the road the second on the
entrance into the site this site is the
alteration cs50x it at the site can see
here on the plans to the left the slide
and from the site looking out towards a
common tree Road on the existing exit
and from the Coventry Road looking back
towards the exit this photograph shows
the Grange here to the left of the slide
an existing parking arrangement this is
another photograph looking from the west
of the site back towards the Grange
showing you the larger car parking area
the proposed engineering works are not
considered to have any adverse impact on
highway safety subject to conditions or
trees subject to conditions it is
therefore recommended that planning
permission is granted for the reason set
out in the officer report Thank You Erin
very much our first speaker please is
mr. Kent
it's counselor Walter Andrew also from
Sam Sam council please do come forward
thank you very much your patience and
it's been a long evening you have three
minutes and I'll give you 30 seconds
warning when you're ready thank you very
much and thank you to committee for
taking the time to consider our
representations evening I'm here
representing south and town council and
our objection which is in your late
representations documentation that
you've received today from officers the
the objection comes in following the
changes to the application where the
actual physical barrier between the
parking areas has been removed which
forgiving my colleague behind here means
that the application is now slightly
bizarre because there is no way of
actually splitting the parking between
the two buildings and we lose a parking
space to the Grange Hall within the site
which as you can see clearly from the
picture up on the screen at the moment
is the bigger and currently more well
used building within the site because
there is also no widening to the roads
on the site because there isn't room to
allow that it is difficult to see how we
will also get to a traffic down both of
the roads both to the north and the
south of that site and the and sorry
both of those providers with it with an
issue on that on the site itself the
members of the planning committee where
well be aware of the site itself but
obviously the Grange Hall is the main
sort of village hall town hall to the to
Southam and then we have the office
building on the
the current one-way system whilst not
perfect does work reasonably well
particularly when you have a lot of
people visiting Grange Hall for
functions and events because it's quite
obvious that there's certainly people
out and want one in one way and out the
other to actually put in the proposed
changes appear on the on the plans we
think we will end up with more chaos and
mayhem with on there the site is already
because of its age under resource for
parking and whilst we don't expect to
get any more parking from this
application or any other application
actually to confuse and complicate the
layout within the site would be worse we
believe thank you very much
members any questions no in that case
thank you very much our next speaker
Thank You committee the Grange is was
setting the presentation was a former
focus of South in rural district care so
that was passed to struck the district
answer as part of local government
reorganisation 1974 as I understand
things and we used it as an area office
until the early 2000s it was then
decided the building was surplus to
strengthen district councils
requirements and we managed to let the
building to water county council who
used it as a time for social services
they've gradually sort of withdrawn in
the building it's been unoccupied for
some time it's a great two listed
building and we've got a duty to
preserve this asset and we've done an
options of praise or and we think the
most viable way to do that is to bring
it into spoken to some sort of economic
and economically viable use we've taken
some devices of marketing that and one
of the issues is that the wider site
contains the Grange Hall which we're not
altering the tenure of
currently the access and egress is
shared between the two buildings that
isn't considered to be particularly
practical if the builders were building
too good to be sort of put into separate
ownership so it was decided that we
would investigate providing a separate
access and egress and that's what prompt
this prompted the applications before
you this evening we appointed a highways
expert to design the proposals and we've
laid from the aged with work and council
highways through our heads from there
satisfied that the in highways terms the
proposals are acceptable it's felt that
this proposed change will give the best
chance of bringing the listed building
back into viable use and we've tried to
design the works to have sort of a
minimum impact both from the building
the setting of the building which is
important
the current pot the current parking
situation and the highway referring to
the objection that the ten counts have
raised I have some sympathy with that
and we had originally proposed sort of
putting a fence to sort of segregate and
to curtilage is the only reason that
we've been removed that is in response
to an objection raised by the
conservation and team we would be more
than happy to reinstate that if the
committee saw fit all to do anything
else to separate if if that would help
in your deliberations this evening Thank
You members any questions council Dixon
mr. perks the photographs we saw on the
exit seemed to recall some fairly
substantial trees that's at top picture
I think isn't it in widening that exit
are those trees in danger of being
either removed or endangered with damage
to their roots we've submitted a full
tree reporting survey as part of the
application
from memory there is one category see
tree that needs to be removed but the
works are considered acceptable in
agricultural terms
I understand there are some requirements
restitutive hand digging in some root
zones but that's all being said they're
just part of the up the arbor cultural
statement Casavant
you've heard what the parish council of
saying i've only become aware of the
detail the tank and still some
objections to see in terms of late
representation and particularly in the
21 days that's a matter for the tank
council to dress as I say when we
originally put the application in we had
proposed separating the two sides and
that would still to be honest be our
preferred option but as I said to
responsive conservation objections we
remove the fence and we're very neutral
mother the fence goes in I whichever the
committee see better any others no very
quickly the fence the line we've got
here I think it's a purple line around
there is that the fence line that was
suggested so you're in and out would be
top right-hand corner only yeah whereas
without the fence you can come in from
both ends I know whatever goes in or not
the designated entrance and exit for the
Grange will be the top of the slide and
the Grange Hall will be the bottom of
the slide so yeah
so Oh so regardless of whether the fence
is there or not the grange itself would
be accessed from the top right hand side
so there's no in there now anymore is
that's both to way yes okay that makes
the objection is the more understandable
with the parking given there's no
boarded fence are those specific spots
set for the grain
and the halls separately or can there be
some crossover with the parking it
depends what the grains gets used for I
think this is probably the first step in
a process
most recently the grains was used as an
office building in the hours of use
meant it compatible for people to share
the spaces and if that were to continue
I I could see that sort of situation so
it's still being acceptable if it when
it depends when it's old what the
proposed uses but that will be subject
to further planning application and
presented to committee in due course of
course this is purely me looking at it
from a logical point of view why would
we segregate for spaces in a bank of
essentially 20 in the top corner there
when we could just have 20 and they're
separated off for the hall and then the
rest of for the Grange that are right in
front of each entrance but that's me
being picky I'm guessing yes I believe
we were there was quite a lot to debates
about D marking and parking spaces as
parts of the application this was a
solution that people seem to feel
acceptable I don't suggest it to the
only solution to it and there may be
solutions that are more practical okay I
go ask my next question of the point of
clarity and yes cancer Allen just
regarding the the fact that the offense
isn't part of the application does that
not mean that the the using of both
entrances as if in and out entrances
isn't necessary required a result of
that demarcation not essential on saying
is there's no there's not going to be a
physical barrier between these parking
areas so why is there a need for two
independent entrances as a result affirm
the application before you this evening
is to form two entrances such that
either now or at some time in the future
we can provide a separate entrance to
the two buildings on the side we had
nominally shown the fence as well we
thought it should sit I think the
reality is we try
establish the principle that you can
access the building separately this
evening and then there is likely to be
further planning application relation to
the Grange which will give more detail
and wine and marketing exercise has been
conducted and there's a potential owner
for the Grange so at the moment we're
seeking permission to create a separate
access for each building where the line
finally goes around it and the fence
lines if there are two defenses now the
parking works are probably matters of
detail the result of the later table at
the sea and we're requesting simply the
planning question to the principle of
the two entrances thanking cancer peri
good evening mr. parks I just wanted
some to go back to this fence business
were various types of fences in terms of
construction discussed with the
conservation area so that there could be
a demarcation of the boundary but
perhaps not so bold and and up in the
face that wouldn't have an impact on the
listed build probably no is the answer
to that question on the grounds and this
is really an application to establish
the principle of the two entrances we
don't have any preference for a style of
fence because as I say we don't really
know what the grains will be useful but
we feel it was important to be able to
market the grains for the potential to
create the second access if and when
offenses ever provided that would come
back to the committee as part of the
listed building application as part of a
larger scheme I would be happy to accept
a condition requiring us to supply
details of an acceptable fence variety
of implementation of the scheme if that
would ease the committee's worry okay
next we're any other quick answer on one
of the thing just appreciate the hope
the grain itself hasn't been in use for
some time but is the are the uses of the
building likely to be at the same time
that would warrant the need for all of
these parking spaces to be divided or is
there not a possibility that they could
practically be shared
they thought the youth I think that's
slightly crystal ball gazing if it works
go for a residential use or something
like that I think it's unlikely that the
residents would want to share the spaces
if it went for a more sort of open
office use it may be acceptable I don't
really want to mislead the committee
into committing something we can't I
think that I think there's a danger
where blaring lines is what's being
providing the the site relatively well
from historical purposes when it was
previously used it didn't appear that
the Grange Hall was used at the same
time as the Grange
very much if you're talking about
developing it for things like
residential that's fair enough for the
market I think we can move on
Kasich's and you look like you might
want to ask a question yeah okay
brilliant cancer folks thanks very much
we have no war member with us Behance to
send something for me to read so let me
just read that to you again in verbatim
dear chairman apologies I cannot attend
in person I would however like to
express my total support for this
application as it is essential to
progressing with finally getting the
Grange building back into use and there
should not be any further delays in its
application regarding so that's our
observation from any questions for the
offices no okay good in that case that's
open to debate who would like to make
their first thoughts cancer Jennings
this is basically about widening the
access points I can see absolutely no
problems at all okay unless there's
anything else to be said we have a
person second day let's move to a vote
in favor you know I must turn thank you
very much in that case committee result
to grant application 1901 949 and ful
with there being no urgent business I
declare the meeting closed
congratulation
grammar